Eepidoki is back and Eepier than ever today I am feeling
extra brain dead today I think it's just from overworking
the last week I think the the 24 hour crash course on tank
it uh really fried my brain so i'm like i used up all my
brains i think like you know it's like no aim no brain must
be a winston mate that's alive that was a propaganda from
tank aunties
it was like a fucking propaganda from the supported dps
players oh my i used my point too much i
I'm so tired.
There was too much thinking involved.
There's too much think.
I think also because I had to learn five tanks and okay, the
fifth tank I learned on the fly.
Literally, I was just like, okay, let me read the hero
description.
I didn't even read, by the way, I didn't even read what the
thing abilities do.
I was just like, I was just pressing.
buttons and just be like okay so i remember in streams
everybody clip i remember watching people right click a lot
on thing and then also uh they jump to people okay that e is
jump i didn't even get a chance to read it too i didn't want
people to know that i was just like i tried to be like fake
it till you make it so i was like super fucking confident be
like i'm gonna pick thing now i think that's the key but i
didn't want to like let you guys know and also let my team
know that YOLOing it.
I was just like, well, it's do or die last.
This could be the last match.
If we lose, then maybe it was my fault for picking thing.
It's right.
I didn't even pull up the things.
I didn't pull up the thing.
Like the the info sheet.
Because I was like, I can't let them know.
I can't even let my stream know.
I'll just let them assume.
I know what I'm doing I I'm just gonna let everybody assume
with full confidence that they know what I'm doing oh yeah I
seem very and then when we did really well during a defense
and it was like oh my god I had I couldn't I had to reveal
it all I was just like guys I had to reveal to you guys and
be like this is my first time on thing guys I can't believe
it's working I was like oh my I had to it was it was eating
me up in the inside also because I wanted to brag I was so
humble anyway I really wanted to gloat that too that's why I
had to I had to break it I had to like let the secret out I
had to reveal it I was Guys, look at this.
So humble.
Anyway, my green is so fried.
I still had to push it back and out.
Also, because it was so fried that...
It was so fried that I legitimately thought...
No one corrected me yesterday!
I was just like, oh my God, guys, I can't believe I have my
paddle and me to greet Samara guys nobody corrected me
yesterday what the fuck guys why did no one correct I was
like oh I have to go practice apex tomorrow for my 1v1
paddle and then um I thought it how are we supposed to know
how are you supposed to know when we did it well I don't
know I assume there'll be one dragon that'll
Mr. Broken Boss, thank you for the super chat, thank you,
thank you.
Anyway, it was so frightening that I thought today was my
1v1 Apex panel, so I woke up early, practiced, like warmed
up, and, oh, God, I feel like, I don't know.
Apparently I found out, I was just like, why can everyone
ain't?
I feel like, I don't know, because, like, Apex is so old
that, um, uh it's so old now that uh um everyone just knows
how to aim in apex now i mean i think apex has some
smoothest movement ever after fucking playing overwatch and
rivals apex movement feels so nice but like i found out that
like everybody uses configs now in apex there's like recoil
configs movement configs um uh uh what was it aim
improvement configs and like it's you can't really ban
people for it because it's configs like it's something you
can like do in the game like you can program in the game
itself so um so apparently that's why like people are so
good at aiming in that game i was like am i washed it could
be both honestly it could be washed and also con like people
are just using configs uh they banned those they don't ban
the accounts they just ban the configs itself configs is
just coding um you know how there's you can It's just coding
in the game that you can put an apex that actually affects
the game itself So my I use for me I use the I use the FPS
configs just so I can have better FPS when I'm playing it
Yeah config files but like oh wait but like um it's also
like like scripting it's sort of like scripting basically uh
but like it's technically not bannable uh yeah so uh like
you it's just editing the game itself for it uh the game
files itself to to basically enhance your own performance uh
but for me i just use the basic ones the ones that everyone
uses where it just gives you fixed fps and better just gives
you fixed fps and better refresh rate uh which helps a lot
because like i remember back in the day people would abuse
the hemlock config where you just go and then he has he was
streaming and he was like uh people he had like a fucking
command where it's like uh exclamation point hemlock and
it's like it is not it is not cheating um because it is a uh
it is allowing epic legends i was like that bullshit there's
no way that's allowed
There's no way that's a lap.
Apparently it is.
Because he never got banned.
He never fucking got banned.
Anyway.
What was I going to say?
Oh yeah.
But I fucking...
I was so confused.
Because I was just like talking to my manager.
Because he was like.
Oh we have to look over all these things for you.
Because I basically was AFK for three days.
I was AFK.
AFK for three days, not, or two days, not responding to
anything or doing any work-related stuff, because I was
like, guys, do not disturb me, obviously, because, like,
the, yeah, the deterrent was so important.
The deterrent was so important, more important than anything
else in my life that I was doing.
It was just bootcamping tank.
I definitely got my priorities straight.
My manager did not want me to join back.
Like when they were like when I was asked to do it would be
the emergency tank.
My manager tried so hard to be like, maybe you shouldn't.
He was like, I'm going to tell you right now that I really
don't think you should do it.
But like this is you.
Like this is on you.
If you do decide to join, this is on you.
I can't stop you, but I don't really approve of this.
Don't listen to him, Toki.
Tank Toki is like, that's right.
If I listened to him, we wouldn't have tank Toki, guys.
Was that...
Tank Toki would not have been born.
So, anyway, I'm like super behind.
on on everything and so I like lost track of like um like
everything that was going on after the tournament um and
then uh and then so um I was like ranting to him about stuff
being like oh man I'm so tired uh blah blah blah blah blah I
also do what you think about my tank do you think I because
I needed someone to give me to what's so I need someone to
give me positive reinforcement
and he's like you did great you improved a lot I was like
yeah I need someone to praise me I need validation exactly I
needed a validation wait let me see if I can remember um
what exactly he's he was like he's basically like my parent
i was like please give me validation um he was like yep you
were doing the callouts even in game uh your tank gameplay i
was just like um i was like oh my god literally clutch
multiple wins with my tank ult and he was like your tank
gameplay was decent your call outs were amazing and i was
like yeah lol
you did amazing i was like did you see that did you see it
you're doing great sport Anyway, and he was like, anyway,
and then he was like, can you please focus on these now?
And I was like, okay, I'll do it after I eat my food.
Did you see it?
I think, and then he was like, I think it is fun.
Oh yeah, and I was just like, do you think I improve a lot
on tanking one day?
I know my mag was terrible, but I think my stranger was
pretty decent i hate mac projectiles so much and he was like
i think it's fun for you to dps slash tank etc and make
content out of it you improved a lot i was like tank is so
boring to play though i hate it and he's like tank is fully
relying on a good deal like it's just so frustrating playing
tank in general unless you have super fancy movement tank be
fun if you hug venom or strange i think you have given a
week or even an extra day i think i put off like a natural
hot carry when you hit those odds think so also but people
did enjoy watching you play and something else than heal not
gonna lie and watch you do good at it and then after it's
like did you do the sponsor tweet and i was like no i'm
tired
I want to take a small nap.
Can you make my waiting room?
Oh my god, I didn't make my sponsor tweet!
Fuck, I forgot to bring it!
Sponsor tweet!
Wait, alright guys, guys, I'm gonna make my sponsor tweet
right now.
I just remember that.
Me reading this.
Dude, it's so hard.
It's okay.
I just remembered it while reading our chat logs.
Like, I fucking can't.
Give me a sec.
How do I make this tweet, guys?
Sorry.
Give me a sec.
I'm still a response.
But, anyway.
Back to my story real quick before I make the...
Where I make my tweet.
And then...
I was like, and then I was like, wait, why is no one at the
server?
I thought no one's there because it was like 10 minutes
before I should have started while I was talking to him.
He's like, and he's like, it's tomorrow.
I was like, I thought it was, I thought I had my panel
today, but it was actually tomorrow.
And then he was like, Doki, if you had, if it was today, you
would be doing tech check for at least 30 minutes ago.
talking to me about Marvel rivals.
I just thought people were lame.
Anyway, uh, anyway, uh, that's why I'm extra eat, beat, and
die.
Magic patiently waiting to talk about work, and then Joki
goes to the bed instead.
Like, magic reaction.
Maddie, thank you for the super chat.
thank you okay guys give me a second let me let me make my
sponsor tweet and then we'll play and then we'll go right
into oh yeah there's so many announcements and stuff i know
everyone's like play the goddamn game doggy but this is so
sad can we get five gifted chips chat thank you for the
super chat hey guys thank you thank you i tweeted about the
dog shirts but not the dog shirts were boring boring in chat
and we sold out you guys did not believe in me my staff
didn't believe in me but look i proved you all wrong we sold
out the batch we brought at oshi uplink obviously it wasn't
the entire no it no we didn't sold out the entire stock just
the batch we brought from for oshi uplink so don't worry
guys There's plenty where that came from.
If you want to get your own doggy share, we still have so
much more.
But before I make my sponsor tweet, we had another guest
announcement.
Yeah.
So after this, we have two more guest announcements after
this.
So another guest announcement.
In three more days, chat.
So, our third guest announcement is the Sloppy Sisters.
Yeah!
So, we're going to be doing more than one song together.
Maybe perhaps two songs together.
And it's going to be me, Lamo, Mint, and Snuffin.
So yes, the Sloppy Sisters will be at the Doki Doki Rewind
Time.
I'm really excited.
Oh, wait, actually, there's three more guest announcements.
Sorry.
My bad.
There's actually, I just don't, you know, I don't know how
to count.
But there's three more guest announcements left over.
And I'm super excited that the Sloppy Sisters are going to
be at the Doki Doki Rewind Time.
I will let you guys know a little behind the scenes we were
originally going to do space jam But then we couldn't get
the perms for it unfortunately But we have an even better
replacement song that is even better than space jam Come on
now, I wanted to use like basketballs too I'll be like oh my
god, we're funny.
We use basketball But it's like a high school musical where
we use the like we're like Troy and we're like He was like
trying to figure out if he wants to sing or play basketball
Bed on it bed on it bed on it bed on it Yeah, get you get
you get you get you head in the game Sorry, I got confused
with golf and and basketball for some reason I was like wait
a minute no that's a golf course song where he's playing
golf I don't know how they both one's ball was clearly a lot
smaller than the other ball like don't keep please I will
say bet on it is more catchy than get your head in the game
I catch it get you get you get your head in the game oh once
you get you get your head in the game a truly common
mistakes balls were involved so like um almost got it right
anyway here i i'll just pin this uh check out the tickets
we're there's still tickets available we sold out on vip and
early early access sorry early admissions i always see when
i see early when i see early access i like g uh e a i just
be like early access instead of early admissions but yes um
um come to the concert we are still working on streaming
tickets uh i don't know how long that's gonna take but we're
still working on it guys apparently it's because it's golden
week right now um it's golden week at the moment in japan so
uh we won't know until i think maybe there's they're
resuming communications after uh golden week yeah you think
about vip is technically
Um, what else?
What else?
Oh, yes.
Wait, okay.
I'm here to prove you guys all.
Everyone doubted me, even my staff.
We have so many dog shirts, guys.
But look at that.
We sold out.
Bam.
Look at this.
Sold out.
For the batch that we brought, we didn't sell all of them.
Please, please keep buying the dog shirts.
Please keep buying the dog shirts We didn't sell out over
like all of our entire We sold out the batch that we brought
in That we brought in for Oshi up Like I knew See guys I
knew it wasn't a mistake It was just a happy accident I knew
it Only 1,000 dog shirts left my dogs too big just buy four
of them and then cut it up and remake the dog shirt if you
buy four of them just cut cut up the the fabric and then
reattach it together and it technically it'll fit your dog
size if you think about it we didn't no no never stop buying
dog shirts guys we still please please we have too many buy
our dog shirts please many thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you or or get a second dog i mean i think
getting a second dog might be easier um imagine and you get
two dogs and a dog shirt if you think about it or do both
get a dog get five six dog shirts get a second dog and then
both your big dog and your small dog um can match anyway let
me do my sponsor tweet real quick i don't know how to do
this what how i need to do to tweet okay there you go um all
right uh i'm gonna copy this i'm all right uh what what
short where's the short okay uh still we're we're still need
okay where's my where's the video oh shit okay let me find
the Let me find a video I'm supposed to download.
Hey guys, thank you for the five gifted ships, thank you,
thank you.
Okay, to be fair, to be fair, I wasn't sent the video
directly, so I need to redownload this.
But, but, but, who did the edit for this?
Is it this?
so you don't need feel free to go on is it this is it this
video oh nike post event final okay i need to listen to this
guys all right there we go i found it i found the video guys
i found out who edited the video all right let's see it does
she even know what she's posting yes i do i do i am a
professional at that being a streamer do not worry they'll
be like stream time starts at 40 minutes guys guys give me a
sec the moment i post this video we can go we can go live
Also, it was really funny.
So I shadow dropped the Enter Heaven cover video.
Doki, finish your sponsor tweet first.
Then you can do story time.
All right, give me a...
Wait, what did I...
What's the name of this?
Okay, all right.
All right.
Let's see.
Bada-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d.
Well, did you in...
Alright, alright.
Did you guys enjoy the concert?
You guys enjoy the concert?
You can re-remember...
You can continue to celebrate with our niece and get...
Up to 100 pulls and 4 SSR!
Nikes for free!
With my link!
Okay, there we go.
I'm just...
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Check out the game here.
Uh...
Alright.
Check out the game here.
There we go.
I did it.
Wait, is that basically what I have to write?
Is that it?
Check out the game here and use the concept exclusive code.
Also, use the exclusive code.
And let's get additional rewards.
Oh, it's too Too much word count I need to get rid of stuff
Oh, I hate that I type, I hate that Oh, no I'm not adding
Nikkei, I guess Oh, I still Oh Uh, use Use Exclusive code To
get additional Awards Uh, check out the game here boom i did
it it's all within the word count do i have to add nike
because then okay uh okay join the nike i don't know i don't
know if i have to add them i'm just going to do it just to
be safe all right now i have to get rid of the i have to fix
the word count How much do I need?
How many...
Okay.
I need to delete.
Three characters!
I know what I'm doing.
I know what I'm doing, guys.
Uh...
Link here.
Link here!
Yes!
I fit the word count!
Alright, there we go.
Bam!
Do you guys see it?
There we go!
I did it, guys.
Professional streamer.
All right, what was I saying about my...
Oh, yes.
The reason why I took Solana to drop that cover is because
they wanted to fix.
I think, like, because I actually asked them, that's why
there's, like, different types of...
I think, like, the other uploads, the ones that were
uploaded earlier, and then they just cut it from the first
video that they gave us.
But I worked with V-show production before, like, you know,
because I worked with them for the other Niki thing.
So I have, like, the director, the director is Discord.
So I asked them, like, oh, hey, is it okay if I could
upload, is it okay if I could upload the video on my
channel?
And he was like, oh, we're actually working on polishing
everything right now.
So what did we send you the HD?
Can we send you the HD version later time?
Because we want to finish, like, we want to reboot.
polished the entire video because they were did it in a
really tight deadline um so we got the director's cut um
because you can if you compare the video from the uh from
the one that was shown on stream and then the one where i
uploaded the fabric is a lot smoother and then like the arms
apparently they don't go through the boobs anymore i mean uh
for go through the c the yeah the boobs
like yeah the the blu-ray directors cut um it's like when
anime brought like you know how like they retouched the
anime uh on the blu-ray release like the the broadcast
versus blu-ray yeah but even the super chat thank you thank
you you're happy there you were able to upload your entry
heaven cover it's so good yeah it's so good they did amazing
with it um but yeah that's why that's why mine was uploaded
later than the other girls just because like um um they
wanted to send me the more hd version of the upload uh
because they're like oh but they're like oh if you don't
want to wait they did give me the option they're like if you
don't want to wait we could send you the original version of
it um and i was like no fuck it i might as well get like if
you i want them to be proud like i want them to be like you
know obviously wanted to fix a lot of stuff um lot of stuff
so i was just like you know what um i'll just wait for the
more polished version since you guys are working on it
anyways and it's i think like it's more representative of
your work uh um if i publish the one that you want me to
publish so that's why i waited to i waited yesterday also
the reason why i didn't tweet about it is because um i was
locked in my room grinding tank and i nothing else in my
mind I just I just wanted to play I just well I didn't want
to but like everything in my head was just learn I got a
learn tank I yeah I was too locked in hmm that's why I
didn't I didn't want to fucking I well I I didn't remember I
I didn't remember to tweet it out or it's just I was just
too preoccupied i had only one thing in my head i i mean i
did upload it because i was like oh i got it popped there
and i was like i'll tweet it later and then there was never
a later i forgot to do a later part all right anyway yes
it's tomodachi lifetime dollars pesos proceed what if we
went pesos oh it's too late now because it doesn't make a
difference, right?
We could have just paid in pesos.
Bite size.
Oh, yeah.
You read that.
Um.
All right.
Oh, sound guy.
Let me know the volume is fine.
Why did I have pesos?
I guess it's because it's NA.
So then, yes.
Use the controls.
All right.
Wow.
I'm using it.
Oh.
I'm using.
it whoa there oh there aren't any residents oh is it too low
all right sound guy is it too low it's just a place for me
characters we'll call it means for short they can look like
real people even people you know and you get to create them
not sure which sort of means to create there are no rules
you can add any means that you dream up as you add means you
can watch them live out their lives they'll chat and play
and even argue it's like an alternative reality what have
you sprinkled oh is that magic but it's that madoka bro the
new madoka outfit fuck new outfit fucking sucks i i can't
believe they gave her a new outfit her original one was so
iconic i was so sad that looks like magic on madoka it's
it's so bad it looks so fucking bad her original outfit Such
was so class.
Wait, let me see.
I can find it.
Madoka, new visual effect, new visual.
All right.
Charlotte, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, hey, Adoki.
Adoki is my birthday.
Can I please get a shout out?
My primary got me here.
Nice one.
Oh, thank you.
That's a keeper right there.
Did you, did you, maybe you can ask him to get, A dog shirt,
too?
You know what would be even more?
You know what would be husband material?
If he buys you a dog shirt.
I can't wait to set it up.
And we're having a great day.
I also hope you make Luna Snow.
Thank you for the Super Chat Stroud.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Stroud.
Happy birthday to you Happy birthday Let me see if I can
find a new visual for Madoka I think it looks pretty ass The
thing is they didn't change Homura's Homura's design They
only change Madoka I don't understand I guess a little bit
Did they change her a little?
Oh they gave her like The little like Oh wait did they?
Main outfit looks the same, but Madoka's main outfit is just
fucking weird.
I guess, like, she has, like, the little arms, like, the
armhole sleeve thing.
I just think it's ugly.
I appreciate it.
I like her classic design more.
Keep it simple.
Let's see.
It was simple, and it was iconic.
Now, I'll show you, guys.
The dress is so ugly.
I made me so sad looking at it.
It made me so mad looking at it.
Yeah, like look, ah!
Ah!
It made me so mad!
She deserves so much better!
She became a god and then suddenly she lost all fashion
sense.
Like, who is this imp- it's so fucking ugly!
I'm so mad!
She deserves so much better.
She suffers enough.
She already goes through so much.
And then you have to give her shit fashion.
Alright, for those who need context, this is her original
outfit.
Yeah, why did you have to remove her drip?
no now look at the comparison oh my god the one one is so
good wait a minute this is the greatest strategy of our time
okay yeah oh yeah that is yeah oh wait a minute wait no
you're right you're right toky oh yeah just me being sad
about docus redesign she had a new vtuber debut and i'm
change and i hate it i hate it change is bad
she had it and then i hate change
um got a few ideas already well hang on them uh for just a
moment while we give the island name you can change this
later all right
doki island not affiliated with any other islands i just
gotta make this clear
all right doki oh where's the
out of man Tokyo Island Yay
Did it not give me Excuse me, do I have to write it again?
Oh my god, I actually pressed cancel I
Tokyo Island
Okay Oh Oh Oh Oh Guys, I'm watching this from my screen.
I'm from my OBS screen.
Which one's the confirm?
It's A.
Okay, I pressed A.
Oh, done.
Okay, done is plus.
There we go.
Yes.
Doki Island Island.
Doki Island Island, yes.
I just...
Doki Island.
Welcome to Doki Island.
island island and not like a red you want to spell it the
text you enter will be used as is how do you pronounce joki
island wait how many not related oh
i don't know why i can't
islands.
I hit.
There you go.
Oh my god, making the me's is gonna be so hard.
Fuck!
Okay!
Oh my god, that's...
Let's see.
God damn, this is gonna be so hard making me's.
This is why I did what I was, I was hesitant streaming it.
related to other islands there we go oh wait what is it I'm
tired wait wait did I just talk to us about islands okay I
was right okay okay I was just like I forgot why I was like,
I spelled it wrong I'm fucking, oh my god I spelled it
correct now Okay, not really The Island It's in I fucking
spelled it right The first time I was just like They're
spelling right It's right in the question Not related to
other islands Islands Not related to other islands Islands
Okay.
Not related to other islands.
Doki Island.
This is our disclaimer.
It's our little disclaimer.
When we see Doki Island, it'll just be like, not related to
other islands.
These are our little disclaimer.
Wait.
to other island yeah there we go you guys and this is why
the doki doki literature club exists hey guys thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you just in case now you can
start adding residents uh uh and see how things unfold let's
aim for six or more residents to give your means plenty of
friends all right we can do that oh welcome to not related
to other island truly isn't smarter than the fifth grade
there are you ready uh gotta me and mine let's invite the
very first resident to doki island island okay you never
create and you just like to get help above maybe like a take
a hands-on give from a scratch a try all right we didn't do
oh bring up overall all right i brought it up all right from
scratch all right we'll make we'll make me first we'll make
jokie bird to a different aspect of your me space browse
these categories on the left okay let's get like a reference
picture of myself of jokie prime real quick guys all right
before we begin screenshots there
we go boom We're making it this face.
Each feature can be changed.
The color position, size of everything.
Well, that's everything.
Feel free to start creating.
I think it's like...
What's the face shape?
It's sort of like that.
And then...
Oh my god, there's two over here.
Which one's the real dokey?
I feel like it's that and then we can edit it a little bit,
right?
Or maybe like...
I feel like this is the best one.
Or like the base?
Uh...
And then we can draw it later.
Oh yeah, we can do...
Ooh, that's too yellow.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Happen Wait, my oh my god wait something crashed
Give me a sec I had something like crash in the background
though what the fuck happened I have to reboot it give me a
sec guys My screen literally flickered.
Sorry my my FBI my FBI agent tried to log on to my So it,
like, crashed my software.
I don't know if you guys saw it.
It was spooky.
Literally, like, blacked out there for a sec.
It's like this yellow.
It's, like, orangey yellow.
This?
Oh, yeah, this.
Alright, I'm back.
Hello.
It's like I never left.
Uh...
And then...
Oh, can I edit this?
Oh my gosh, so many customization options.
Oh!
No!
Oh, wait, no!
That's not what we want.
Oh, this is where I get the bang option here.
Oh, I see.
I don't think they have it, though.
Maybe like this?
Uh, yeah, they can swoop the other way.
But I don't think we have one that swoops the other way.
Okay, back.
Then we, for the back, we get this.
Wait, where is the crunchy back?
No?
Oh, this one.
No.
Where's the crunchy one?
Yeah?
I guess?
Wait, there is an option.
Oh my god, I'm playing it through my OBS right now.
So give me a sec.
What is the option down here?
Oh!
There we go.
I know.
There's no other colors, though.
It's either yellow or orange.
I feel like this is as close as it can get.
I guess we could do that.
Hit.
And your SF fade?
Oh, I could.
Wait.
And I can make it orange fade here.
Or like this fade.
Ooh, I
like that.
That's nice.
I should want to look at the front.
It's so hard to do.
I just downloaded the hair.
Download a me.
I can't believe Nintendo got rid of it.
Nintendo was like, we know what you'll get up to.
But they forgot.
They forgot we can still screenshot stuff and take pictures
on our phones.
They can't stop us from creating.
They can't stop our creation.
Creativity, they're like, we gotta make sure we gotta make
sure you can't up.
They tried to avoid the Kirby situation.
The fucking bikini Kirby's.
Doki, true.
Yeah, apparently you can't even screenshot on your Switch.
You have to do it through another program.
I can't believe it.
I can't download myself.
You wouldn't download a Doki, would you?
Basically, they had an issue where they gave people freedom
to draw their ship or whatever in the Kirby Racers that
game.
And then people drew one of the Kirby characters in a bikini
or in a swimsuit.
And they got taken down.
It got taken down.
It was too sexy.
And Nintendo was...
And then Nintendo's like, we can't let this happen again.
We can't...
Because we cannot have a repeat of this.
I think this is the closest we can get.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, this one.
This one or...
Oh, maybe this...
No, this one is the closest for the hair swoop.
Alright.
Yeah.
We're good to go.
Okay, and then Down
All right All
right, let's see I don't mean that Oh, what's this?
Oh, this is where we can Place stuff
Okay, I actually need to hide myself for a little bit.
Give me a sec.
I can't know what.
Oh, that's how they customize it to make it more like I'm
angry.
I wish I could make it so that it's one up and one down.
Maybe I'm just always.
Yeah, I can get really creative.
Alright.
Oh my god, I can't even see my eyebrows.
Okay.
Wait, what was the color before?
What was the default, guys?
I want that one.
Or I'm just always worried.
Yeah, I want to give myself the dream workspace.
I'm so sad.
I can't give myself the dream workspace.
It just doesn't look good when it's like yellow.
It'll be like cute.
hard to see all right eyes
i just i don't even think i'm making my more
i'm so jealous of everyone who can make beautiful mees right
now i don't know what the I'm doing I'm
just EEPI all the time this is how I feel in me and this is
how I feel right now honestly this is how I feel at the
moment where's the where's the mischievous eyes which one is
it a post tank toky I
know they have one What looks mischievous?
Where is the smug?
Oh, there it is.
I guess?
That's like the most smug one they have.
I feel like this is the most smug.
Or maybe this.
Wait.
oh that one is just this without i think maybe this yeah
this seems like the most smug out of all of them you can try
rotating that would work oh
let's reset that oh my god what i'm not even making myself
anymore i i don't even know what i'm making.
It's a better.
Which part?
Don't be pleased.
It's like
it's like chirp.
It's like this.
Yeah, this is the color.
Oh, I can add eyelashes.
Oh.
No, I don't want that.
What's this?
Oh, it's eyeshadow.
YouTube play button.
So you know I'm on YouTube.
It reminds me of making a dragon on your island.
I'm sure they want to be friends with Doki Bird.
Thank you, the super chat.
All right, thank you, thank you.
I'll think about it.
First time, we got to get through the...
We have to make sure we can make myself first.
Hey, guys.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, yes.
Executive Dead is being short-sighted.
Oh, that's time.
Okay, thank you, the super chat.
chat thank you thank you guys we gotta first off we gotta
figure out how to make myself first i'm only like there's no
black dot in there and then it would look good
oh can i change the color of that or no oh i can't this
doesn't look right i had to draw it myself for some shit
like Too much life in them, I know.
I know.
Okay.
This is one I usually...
Let me see if there is another alternative.
I think this is, like, the best one out of all of them,
honestly.
I think there...
Yeah, out of all of them, this one looks the most smug one.
What the fuck is...
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Yeah, the nose.
Oh, my God.
Maybe let...
Can I make this?
God, I'm so bad.
I'm making these.
Oh, wait.
Is there a smug mouth?
Oh!
Yeah!
wait it has to be bigger
yeah okay is this sad how big do we wait what's this oh it's
lipstick
okay wait wait oh wait shit too much okay now now i'm
cooking now i'm now i'm cooking guys now it's It's all
coming together, chat.
Oh, yes.
It's all coming together.
Big, map.
It needs to be big.
How big, though?
That?
You're like that.
Yeah.
Wait, okay.
That's how...
Or...
Big!
Okay, we do that.
Then we move the nose up more.
Oh my god, it's perfect!
It's actually perfect!
Okay.
Wait.
We're cooking, guys.
We're cooking!
Okay, now it's actually coming together.
Now everything actually, it's actually coming together,
chat.
What the fuck is this?
What the fuck is that?
That's no glasses.
Not yet.
I still got some life in me.
It's just...
She's so... Oh my, now I'm a vampire.
Now I'm Edward Cullen.
I just want to see the options.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, I could give myself Freckles.
Okay, now we are at the face paint.
Yes.
Alright, let's see.
Let's try this.
In this zone, on the right, you can also edit tool options
like color and type.
okay it's easy to draw here using touch controllers let's
get right to it
all right let's see how well i do this it's gonna be pretty
rough i don't want to know what cut okay pro yes okay tools
mark have this shown adjustable settings try opening the
settings here by touching the button or pressing X.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
You can also change the color palette using that.
Try opening a setting screen by touching Y.
You can switch back to previous mode.
Alright.
Um.
Okay.
I'm going to try not to be too overwhelmed here.
Um.
Setting Shape Sticker Oh, I can add stickers Oh my god What?
Okay Text Drag What is that?
Oh, it's paint tool Okay, what is this?
this what the fuck is oh it's like the layers okay i would
like a grid please uh what the fuck is down there okay
that's easy mode okay um what is this guys what the fuck is
this
Copy, mirror, paste, too.
What is this?
What is this little shape over here?
Why is there no information?
What the fuck is this?
What does this symbol mean?
What does a symbol mean?
Oh, my God.
I don't understand what that means.
symbol means okay we're gonna grab this color and then oh my
god oh I'm so overwhelmed right now okay smooth um um yeah
what is this
okay that's layers and then
give me a second trying to process all of this right now
this is too many information this is too much how do i
symmetry tool this chat it's okay i'm so overwhelmed i'm so
overwhelmed i thought you guys said there was a symmetry
tool where i turn illuminate on what the fuck did i turn on
oh mirror paste a copy okay all right
oops like color range oh wait what the fuck okay wait um
is this color okay uh
i don't want to delete this where's ctrl z where's ctrl z
okay wait oh my god where did it go no no delete Give two
hours.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, oh, left bumper.
Okay, okay.
All right.
I feel like a grandma right now.
Like, how do you download Facebook, Dragoons?
I want to use Facebooks on my phone.
Oh, my God.
Why did I do it straight?
What was I expecting?
All right, everybody's doing stuff online now.
Can you help me download Facebook on my phone, dragon?
We're trying to learn code.
Oh, my God.
Did you see that video of that fat woman breaking those
glass bridge?
I can't believe people do so many people die dragons and
prayers thoughts and why is my line smooth
it's so sad that I have it is because I select this move
is this look okay is it yeah how do I I get the color of the
I'm trying to get this color.
I don't even remember what color that was Why do you see we
want to be the Mona Lisa
It's in the color palette.
I don't remember like oh oh oh I see it guys.
I see it thoughts and prayers okay i got this guys
there you go and then we fill it up oh fuck did sponge bob
now it what if i just go in with this as dokey i
that's like that's her now
okay okay that's Oh my god, I feel so slow And if this is
exactly why I was thinking about not streaming Tomodachi
Like Okay Uh The fuck is Okay, ZL Uh Wait, wait, where, why,
what, how did, oh,
and then, oh,
that's close enough.
That's close enough.
Wait, and then do I do?
I'm cooking?
Okay, and then I'll do...
A little hair.
Here we go.
That seems right, I think.
That almost looks like me.
I'm pretty sure.
And then...
Here we go.
Perfect.
yeah and then there must be a there must be an X here
somewhere all these shapes and no X I can do this please
don't let me cook okay okay oh no not that oh did I passed
by it?
That's a foot.
Oh my god, I can give myself anime eyes.
Oh my god, customization is insane.
I could just use a text box.
You're so right.
Why make this more difficult than it should be?
Oh shit, that's the wrong color.
Okay, wait, it was in there?
How could I miss such an
symbol where is it oh I see it okay but that's not the X we
want we should just use the text though I didn't text is
better all right and
then with the bring it up I don't bring up my X X marks the
spot how do I bring this up I don't know why why is it
behind Oh shit we might have to throw this away
I can't draw on top of bangs
Are you fucking kidding me
What the fuck how do you do this Okay I got an idea
Oh I I forgot you still my idea to draw I still continue to
draw on top of it
that's my idea I guess draw on top setting
where's that click
on the smile face next to the reset oh oh paint on top there
we go
Oh my god, we're learning tech, guys.
Okay, never mind.
Never mind.
I don't think it's working, guys.
I don't think it's working.
One guy.
Oh, no.
I gotta make my own things.
Okay, we can fix this.
Okay.
And then, oh my god, it's beautiful.
Oh my, all right, we can...
We'll remove the bangs.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, we'll figure this out.
We'll figure this out.
All right.
We can make this work.
Okay.
And
then...
Did it work?
Is it working?
Guys, I see you thinking.
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
I think it's working.
Alright, and then we can add the egg.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
color color oh fuck okay and then I think I think it's
almost one to one guys you think it's working you think it
looks one to one I think I think it's working guys um there
you go and then And then...
Uh...
Okay, and then...
And then we gotta fix this.
Oh, shit, not like that.
It's not how we fix it.
That's Doki...
It's Doki Me!
That's me!
Ugh...
There we go.
And then...
I have good hand-eye coordination if you can't tell.
Ta-da!
It's a masterpiece.
I did it!
Ta-da!
Looks just like me.
Guys, this is why I wish I could just download a me.
Let's do this here.
And then, uh, I mean, that's it.
I think I've perfectly created myself.
Right here.
It literally looks like me.
Oh, maybe a little crud.
Like that.
No, that doesn't look.
Grit.
Okay, maybe what?
There you go.
And Chikori, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I think I did it.
I think I made myself.
There we go.
I think...
I think I did it.
It's just like me.
Everyone else has such beautiful mees of me.
How did they all do it?
I'll never understand.
I'll never understand, guys.
How do they all do it?
I can't tell which is which.
Wait.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Oh, that's it.
Oh, shit.
That's an issue.
Okay, I didn't realize.
Oh, shit, I forgot.
I didn't realize that that could have been an issue.
All right, we can fix this.
All right, let me see if I can get a band that covers.
There we go.
There you go.
It looks more natural now.
All right, here we go.
I did it.
The first jokie, we're done now.
Because I'm tall.
I'm so tall
Alright It's how tall I am No you're not I should be like I
think this height I'm pretty sure Alright let's get a few
details You can always change this info later Alright
Dokey Bird Should I be dokey or just dokey.
I think, I think, are dokey or just a dokey bird?
I just, I think dokey.
Let's just be like, dokey.
Or dokey bird.
Do you want dokey bird or dokey, guys?
A horse.
Alright.
We'll be, because I'll be like, I'm dokey.
And then, uh, uh, it'll be doki it'll just be doki my name
is doki
my name is doki my name is doki my name is doki my name is
doki
um i'm trying to remember okay Should I actually be that
tall?
Yes, I should be that tall.
Female.
Angelou.
For.
What happens when I...
Wait, can she die?
Wait, can my me die?
Wait a minute.
Wait.
Can my...
Can my me die?
I need to know before I click.
Don't age.
No?
Okay, then why the fuck is there an age thing?
Don't age.
If I could have gravestones of my mees?
What does age have to do with this?
Oh, she will become old.
Don't age.
What is this?
Oh, I could pick.
My name is Doki.
My name is...
Wait, I can like...
My name is Doki.
Okay, let's do custom.
It's nice to...
My name...
My name is Doki.
My name is...
My name...
My name is Doki.
It's nice to meet you.
Doki.
My name is Doki.
My name is... My name is... My name is Doki.
It's my name...
Guys, I can't tell!
I can't tell!
My voice is so unique, I can't even know!
If I can do this!
How does this voice sound?
More speed?
Oh yeah.
My name is Doki.
meet you meet you my name is dokey my name is dokey it's
nice to meet you my name is dokey it's nice to meet you my
name is dokey it's nice to meet you all right guys how do i
do this second 2026 how do i do this how does this voice
sound guys how do i do this behind to meet you It's nice to
meet you.
My name is Doki.
No, we're not getting two, guys.
A bit higher.
My name is Doki.
It's nice to meet you.
Okay.
May 2nd, 2026.
Higher pitch?
Okay, speed.
My name is Doki.
It's not my...
I don't talk that fast, guys.
It's nice to meet you.
Like that?
Today is May 2nd, 2026.
26 so how does this voice sound oh my god my chat keeps
lagging i need that let's pull it all right 26 so i do talk
fast my name is doki my name my name is my name is doki it's
nice to higher pitch okay my name is doki it's nice to meet
you all right is that better So, how does this voice sound?
How does this voice sound?
No, that's so high.
My name is Doki.
Today is May 2nd, 2026.
It's nice to meet you.
2026.
So, how does this sound?
My name is Doki.
Today is May 2nd.
It's nice to meet you.
My name is Doki.
All right, we'll do this.
I settled.
Quick.
Honest.
Chill.
Quirky on this
shirt.
All right, varied movement quick.
Maximum quirk is so worse.
Liar.
Why is it honest versus polite?
What the fuck?
I guess in the middle.
thinking middle quick quirky all right yeah i'm not okay i
don't say i'm not polite nor honest but what does that even
mean i'm chill guys i'm so chill i'm is it blunt i guess
i'll be more like here i guess i'm so chill can you be
honest and light there we go oh more to the right all right
it's all max let's just do all max out that's it was all in
we're all in all right let's see it all right can i do
everything more than one Alright, let's do everything.
Oh, me.
It's 8.
It's been set.
Uh.
Event outfits.
No otters.
Okay.
Alright.
I think we're good.
Our first me, guys.
Welcome.
Welcome to Doki Island.
Social optimist.
Passionate follows their instincts.
Go get it.
Bold and captivate.
Their wit and charm.
Light up a room.
It's never a dull moment when they're around.
That's me!
You might have color paths that correspond to your
personality types.
The colors in that palette will show up in different ways.
Like their clothing in the default of their house.
I do not know how people can draw memes, guys.
I don't understand how y'all do it.
We did it, guys!
She's here!
Huh?
Oh, hey.
I don't think we've met yet.
I'm Doki.
I'm an outgoing go-getter who loves exploring new ideas.
I tend to do whatever comes to mind.
That's me!
Here's my profile card.
Except what chance suits you the best?
What?
Hello?
Oh, my hand!
You're not related to others caretaker, right?
What should I call you?
You're not related to other caretaker.
Okay.
Doki.
Doki, how's it going?
Oh, wait.
How?
Wait, you're right.
Okay.
Only it matters if it's capped or not.
Duchess, having a nice evening.
Oh, that sounds good.
Wait, how much can I type?
Okay, that's much.
Like, text itself can, but the pronunciation will need to be
shortened.
Duchess 22.
WW.
Let's throw that.
When all usernames are taken.
Oh, by the way, what's your birthday?
Wait, which one?
Okay.
Let's see.
Let me double check real quick.
Alright, I found out.
Oh, that's the same day as my birthday.
Really?
You know, Dutch is 22.
WW, WW, WW, WW, WW, getting a good look at you now.
It's like I'm staring at a mirror.
Oh my god!
All right.
We have the same birthday, guys.
What a coincidence.
A feelings bubble has disappeared over Doki's head.
That means that Mia is pounding something.
Let's try talking to Doki to see what's up.
What's going on, Doki?
Good evening.
Hey.
Hey, Doki.
It's on your mind.
I'm banished.
Oh, okay.
I can feed you.
It's Doki is hungry.
That should be used to hand them.
Only we weren't on a remote island.
Go ahead.
Oh!
It's just in time.
It's a food mart.
Now snacks aren't free, but since we're celebrating it,
edition of your first island resident.
Here's $200.
$200 runies?
But check out the food, Mara.
See if there's something that Doki would like to eat.
Okay.
Doki, what do you like to eat?
Welcome.
Looks like they have brand new items every day on their
daily specials.
Be sure to check back often.
And you can shop for items you previously bought using these
icons.
Alright, that's cool.
I can work with that.
I want to get hot pot tonight.
Oh, speaking of hot pot.
Alright, fried egg, butter, cookie, nachos.
Oh, I can't draw any yet.
I'll get a fried egg.
Ooh, wait, nachos sound good right now, too.
Ooh.
Oh, my God.
I wish I could just take a picture and then make a Mia.
I'm gonna nacho.
Wait, I can get an egg?
Oh, my God.
I have $200.
I can get a...
Sorry.
Thank you very much.
Oh, nachos.
We're nice.
Now let's get back to your house.
Don't get got you nachos.
Alright.
And now give...
Press X.
And you want to give her...
The me something.
Okay.
That was irresponsible use of your mutt.
Just like the real donkey.
You like nachos.
here you go oh oh you want it oh my oh you want the nachos
don't you oh here you go toky better like it i have i bought
25 nachos she liked it oh nachos number one oh she's so
happy and grace when you help them resolve some good likely
happen if you keep them happy okay my happiness jar it's up
oh my god money well i know what to do with that money more
nachos learn them by taking care of the means that live on
your island you collect enough something good is bound to
happen now that you're done helping press b to head back
outside okay
bird you can customize your island too Like, you can, you
can, like, terraform your island.
I don't know exactly.
Tell me about your life.
Living the dream.
I'm not related to other Aeolian.
Yay!
So, but that's your life.
Living the dream.
Welcome to Tokyo Island Island.
Roll the credits.
Finally, we're here.
It feels like the island's coming live with me living here.
Very important disclaimer.
You're trying to kill your means and have fun on Doki
Island.
Okay.
Oh, one more thing.
Make sure you save before closing heap a record of
everything that happened.
You can save at any time.
Just press X to bring up the menu of the save option.
Save.
please please just save my don't stop I was just doing a
tutorial can I use settings for it oh player settings oh
it's like when all right but baby settings okay so that's
just the settings though hello that's me I can edit it too
all right there's only me right now Hi.
Hey, Toki.
Good evening.
Hey.
What are you thinking about?
More.
I require more food.
Want more food?
Yeah, got you.
More nachos.
Yum.
Yum, yum.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Yay!
I'm so happy.
Double up!
More!
money oh she leveled up every time that happens you have to
give the me who level up a new gift choose a gift little
quirks expressions what's the best type of gift to give are
me chat I'm worried if I click it I won't be able to back up
and see the other options what's meta guys guys what's meta
in Tomodachi life Whatever it's meta.
Okay, quirks.
Okay, we'll do little quirks.
When you give me a little quirk, you're giving a new
personality trait.
Can it make me act more like a person they're based on or
not?
Do a plenty.
Watch how your muse behavior changed and you always change
later.
Okay.
Greeks proudly.
Oh, it's just...
It's proudly.
Or flirtation.
Okay, okay.
Wait, greets with a non-greets with a...
Won't greet anyone.
Greet karate.
Oh my god, they're all so good.
They're all so good, though, guys.
They're all...
Oh, no.
I'm always posing.
Always so cool.
Okay.
Rodeo ride.
Wait.
The rodeo rider actually fits me more.
Okay, you guys.
Okay, guys.
Guys, rodeo rider.
Those who might have worked with the calibrate.
Okay, rodeo rider.
Okay, rodeo rider or stand smugly chat.
What?
Rodeo rider.
Okay.
Rodeo.
I'll do rodeo rider.
Here you go.
Yippe-kaye, Doki.
I feel like I'm becoming my true self more and more.
Yeah, you are, Doki.
Pretty happy, but it looks like things are going well.
Speaking of me, is what happy give this one a head rub.
Don't be shy.
Put your hat on Doki's head and give it a little rub.
Don't make this weird, Doki.
Yay!
He wants a little pat.
She really liked that.
Leon said, select the reading once again.
I don't think it was super chat.
Thank you.
You collect a fair amount of warm fuzzies.
What does warm fuzzies give me?
Oh!
me news oh my god look at me go here's what's happening on
our island a wishing fountain has been constructed a wishing
fountain the island's resident is excited quoted as saying
finally somewhere to take a bath it was me I'm the island's
resident there's only one resident I interviewed myself for
this report thank you Thanks for watching.
I'm Doki, and you're up to date.
It's like Obama giving himself a medal and being like, good
job, Obama.
Thanks, Obama.
Thanks, Doki.
Let's go take a peek.
All right.
Let's go to the fountain.
What is this?
Wow!
Why is it yellow?
I think yellow might have been, like, a mistake.
mistake for color to use.
Your island now has a wishing fountain.
It will grant wishes in exchange for warm fuzzies.
The more wishes, the more you'll unlock.
Plus, you're likely to unlock even more.
Island comes along.
Notice I've collected a lot of warm fuzzies.
It's a good time to stop the fountain.
Okay.
I want...
I want a little quirk.
Wait, I want to strut your stuff.
Walks.
Oh, yes!
I'm getting a meta build
Like, it could be any other color Why yellow?
Why piss?
Oh, I have another one?
What is the goods?
Yoga Street dancing.
Oh my god, Doki should...
Oh my god, wait.
Oh, god, damn it, level 6!
Wait, what about quirks?
I'm gonna get the...
I'm gonna get the street dancing.
Wait, soccer!
I love soccer!
Wait, actually, street dancing.
I think street dancing is cool.
Yay!
Doki, I got a gift for you!
Doki!
She's about to break it down.
Good evening.
Oh, what's going on, Doki?
So lonely, being the only person I'm not related to other
Kind of gives me the heebie-jeebies too I wish there were
other people here with me Okay, yeah, I can make you another
resident doki That's the perfect chance to try adding
another me Press X to open the menu and select add a me Okay
I can make another one I actually wanna I wanna change Uh
what's my island name oh i want to be not related to other
islands islands okay out of me all right what is get help oh
that's what it does there's not therapy okay all right from
scratch okay
have an idea okay wait i need to grab the encyclopedia
all right let me grab the encyclopedia real quick all right
let's see what me should we make first oh i have an idea
okay i have an idea wait i Actually, what me should I make
first?
There's so many me's.
I have an idea.
Okay, this is a better red.
And then...
Do I not have a...
Do I not have a bald?
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
It's a true form.
I don't think I have eyebrows.
I don't know if it... Okay, yeah, and then...
I think this eye works the best.
Okay, this just looks like a pervert.
It looks like a pervert with that eye.
Okay, yeah, that works.
Oh, and then...
There you go.
Oh, yes!
It's perfect!
It actually is perfect.
Wait, is there a baby hair?
Where is it?
Let's say, like, do a baby hair at the top.
Is there a hair?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, my God, wait, they...
Oh, my God, wait, it works.
I want to make the head, like, shorter.
If only I can make it a little short.
It's perfect.
And then, mouth.
Oh, my God.
What mouse should we do?
I feel like it'd be this.
Or...
It should be like...
Maybe...
Is that or...
A kissy face?
No.
Is that that or maybe...
This?
But...
Yeah, I have to hide myself again because I can't see.
The dream works, fate.
Either that or maybe...
I wish I could change the cut.
Oh, can I?
Oh, I can't.
I don't know.
I don't know if I want to do that or maybe...
Or maybe this phase.
Open mouth?
Yeah, but he doesn't have teeth.
Sorry, she does.
That's me.
She doesn't have teeth.
I know sometimes I can make that face.
Okay, wait, I might need a reference picture.
Yeah, tomatoes don't need teeth.
I was like, wait, that's me.
Okay.
I'm gonna grab a reference don't worry I have a lot of them
okay oh I need to make the eyes wait further away all
right there we go oh that's perfect that's actually perfect
and then okay the mouth I could do that
can I squish oh I can wait you're right I should squish the
Irish more
upside down lips all right let me make the upside upside
down lips which one oh i can make it late no i should oh no
no not the pom-pom put in butthole
there you go wait i think it works wait this works there we
go we did it We rotated Wait, that's good, it's perfect We
rotated it Upside down
That's actually perfect Oh, mountain used to be Closer to
the eyes Yeah, but it would look good Oh
Okay, it's perfect It's perfect Hello, Doki Welcome to the
island I don't think we even need face paint I think it's
perfect Oh wait, we do We do, we do need to add face paint
What I want to do that
I can't give you a sec I can add the shine I swear
Oh my How do people do this I keep looking at the circle.
Here we go.
Ta-da!
Yay!
Alright.
There we go.
It's clean.
My god, look how big that is.
Alright.
dance Doki dance yes keep dancing all right and that's per
the plan that we decided early on my
name is Doki all right I think female I don't think tomato
have a gender guys I don't where's the tomato option chat
where's the female the fruit they do I think tomatoes are
non-binary all right wait
I can make
Oh shit
Actually the tomatoes should be the oldest Alright don't age
150 Be more Mori of the tomato The ancient one My name is
Doki My name is Doki It's nice to meet you
Wait, can can the tomato rot?
Can the tomato rot is that?
Since you're all probably 69 years old and what is Doku not
just a retirement home, but stop thinking of super chat
Thank you.
We are we are ageless My name is Doki My
name is Doki.
It's nice to meet you.
Yes.
Today is my second, 2026.
So, help.
My name is Doki.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is my second, 2026.
So.
How does this voice sound?
My name is Dopee.
Let's pitch all the way up.
Holy shit!
No!
My name is Dopee.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is Dopee.
There he is.
Yes.
Do you share a real-life family or relatives of Doki?
Your island residents will initially recognize it, but
opportunities become aware of them might pop up as they
spend time together.
Grandparent of Doki.
The Mies will not...
Yeah, please don't fall in.
Good.
Don't quit.
Actually...
Okay.
Unless...
I'm thinking.
I'm...
Self-love is very important.
I'm thinking...
Unless...
What do you mean?
Do not pet the tomato.
What is that reality TV show on the island?
Was it Love Island?
Do we?
I'm thinking.
Because if we make everybody related to tomato, it might...
All right, let's see.
All right, no relationship.
Do we do it?
No relationship or yes relationship.
Or, no!
It's self-love?
Or a grandparent?
We'll see how it goes.
We'll see where tomato dokey is gonna end up with.
I mean, he's a tomato, so he's like...
I don't think she's...
Is that...
Very serious.
Very quirky.
Do you believe in self-love?
I will do more honest.
Yeah, tomatoes are a very serious business.
You're so right.
All right.
All of above.
Uh.
Adder is okay.
all right add me yeah reserved aloof logical tenacious
cautious speaks matter factly thoughtful introspective great
at thinking things through and analyzing from every angle
that's right that's how the parasite was born pronouns
tomato Hey, Doki.
I'm curious and curious, but I can be a bit too shy, too
short sometimes.
Then again, we're all looking at ourselves.
I suppose I'm looking forward to living here.
What?
Hey, Doki.
I heard someone named Doki just moved to not related to
other.
Yeah.
You're just hoping the beam up, I mean dot Doki gets in the
island.
No name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's right, Doki.
You got a new friend.
It's Doki.
What's this?
Y and X.
Oh.
They can go.
Oh, they can choose nicknames for each other.
Oh, that's cool.
all right are you gonna meet now that your island has two
residents you should help them get to know each other you
need to go outside
okay oh wait is he getting closer does he hey no no go back
come back go talk to doki
Hello, it's nice to meet you.
My name is Doki.
Hey, Doki.
I'm Doki.
Doki and Doki are getting familiar.
Oh, look.
They're learning about technology.
They're like by the people.
I would expect so.
Alright.
Yay.
I have fun chatting with that's great by guide means you can
help them get to know each other and grow closer the little
relationship on their own but a little helping hand can
speed things along try guiding into them into each other's
path and sometime soon something different is likely to
happen all right that's true all right doki and doki are
having a fun time
um oh five residents okay well and then hold it grab them
and drop them near us give it a try sometime soon okay back
over here wait where is nope doki is inviting doki to chat
for a little bit okay doki doki is enjoying it doki is also
enjoying it joki was not enjoying it joki's trying his best
to redo it joki enjoyed it so much you're so funny oh my god
joki let's go
thank you
You're starting to see each other's face.
Guys, the jokes aren't racist, just so you know.
Doki!
Doki, no!
I can't get canceled!
Doki!
No!
Oh yeah, it should give Doki a little rub.
No.
Yeah.
Doki, no.
She really liked that.
Yeah.
It was a turn who liked chatting with Doki.
She's just so easy to talk to.
I am!
Oh wait, I didn't mean to pet you.
You want a little...
You want food?
Yeah, I got you some nachos.
Yo!
Yeah!
See, they both like nachos!
They're so like-minded!
Wait, I think Doki levels up.
Oh no, Doki doesn't level up.
What if I- I'm just gonna give you another nacho, and then
you can actually level up.
Doki on the back!
Don't turn around, Doki!
It's like the Jason Momoa picture.
Oh.
Alright, fucking fine.
The most dokey conversation is what I showed you guys.
The Twitter memes I liked and bookmarked.
Alright.
Alright, dokey and dokey are having a good time.
This is too real.
Oh, wait.
Are you thinking about Doki?
This is so sad.
Doki, you need some furniture.
Good evening.
What is it, Doki?
I want to be friends with Doki.
Great.
That's it.
Okay, do I have to be...
Where do I position myself?
That's a bad...
No, great idea.
What should we talk about?
um let's see why don't you give them something to talk about
what would be a person a thing a thing a person thing
activity something else oh an activity
this will work every time every it should work on every
dokey
it works every time
Hey, Doki.
Good evening, Doki.
Do you feel like talking about...
Marvel Rivals?
What?
But what?
Oh, that's a good question.
I don't think you'll find anyone on all of not related to
other who's better at Marvel Rivals than me.
Oh!
So true!
So true, Toki!
Oh my god, it's amazing!
Oh my god, not to brag or anything, but I don't think you're
gonna find anyone's kid that's better rather than me, I
don't think.
Let's go!
What would be...
Wait, what are the options?
Doki.
It'll be Doki.
And then we're going to figure out which Doki they're
talking about.
We'll never know which Doki they're talking.
Doki.
Do we keep it all Doki's?
So then we'll never know which Doki they're talking about.
It'll just be all Doki.
Keep it all Doki.
Like Doki and doing like, but which one?
Because we are so...
Brass.
My new Marvel rivals would bring Doki and me together.
I hope Doki shows.
I hope Doki shows the trade.
These two have become friends.
Mew Stars has put their relationship with what they love in
all sorts of ways as they grow closer.
Friends, sweetheart, and beyond?
You get to watch your relationship.
But also, maybe you nudge them slightly in one direction or
another.
The more resin you have, the more ways they can connect with
each other.
But back to these cities, they're island first, which is
hugely around.
Let's see if it makes the local news.
It's going to be on the local news.
Oh my god, Doki's doing the news.
We have clothes.
Clothes for the Doki's.
I'm on the news, guys.
Thanks for watching.
I'm Doki.
Oh my god.
What a great news channel.
Oh, oh, they want us.
Oh, they want me to make another me.
Okay, let me save Don't stop wait, I can Island info.
Okay, we're gonna Edit this not related to other island.
Okay, we gotta do island because not related to other
Something I don't like when they said that other islands
There we go not related to other islands island island there
we go wait what's island lingo the phrases these are stored
here you don't use that lingo in their conversation with
your own unique phrases okay okay we're gonna have fun with
that all right we gotta add another resident from scratch
all right all right resident number three
idea okay all
right oh wait no not that oh okay whatever it's just default
uh
let's see i need to look at the wikipedia guys which dokey
is this we'll find out soon guys we're gonna find out soon
i'm just looking at the wikipedia the dokepedia right now
This one is also, like, pretty pale.
Okay.
This one, I think?
Yeah, we don't need to draw anything.
Luckily.
Luckily, we don't have to draw anything.
I think this bang work.
Yeah?
Or is it this one?
No, it's this one.
And then the back side.
Oh, is that just a ponytail?
Well, I have to do sets?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, pfft.
Trust the process, guys.
Oh, okay, there we go.
There you go.
I was going to say, trust the process, everyone.
And trust the process.
It seems like...
backside with the the double this is all sides right oh wait
oh there it is wait I didn't see it because I covered my
guys I'm just watching it through my OBS right now oh my
there it is okay we can fix this
what do we mean oh my god I forgot what I look what okay
we're just gonna put the profile picture up we're gonna keep
looking at it
Don't worry, I've saved pictures.
Where is my screenshot of myself?
Okay, no, I have to make...
I gotta save a new picture.
Guys, I don't think...
Okay, there is an issue.
Where is this?
But, like...
Are there hats in this game?
Are there...
Guys, are there hats in this game, guys?
Because we gotta figure it out.
Yes?
Oh, they are?
Okay, I don't have to draw the hat, thank God.
Because I was thinking, do I have to draw the hat or not?
I don't want to draw the hat.
Later on?
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
That's later on.
Where can I put this as a...
Where can I put this to look at it?
Here we go.
There we go.
I'll draw the ribbons, maybe.
I think the ribbon will be good to draw.
Yeah, all right.
This one.
And then...
Draw longer?
Oh, wait.
That's good.
Maybe that.
I think that's good.
I think that would work the best, actually.
That or...
Oh, no, that.
That works the best.
Uh...
And then...
Color.
It's like light yellow.
Holy shit, that's so yellow.
Okay, it has to be this yellow.
Oh, unless...
It'd be like this yellow, right?
The first, the light yellow, or the darker yellow.
I pressed the wrong button accidentally.
I tapped too fast.
That's why it's on the guy.
The middle one is too, too, oh, it's too neon.
Okay.
Alright.
Welcome to Doki Island, home of Doki Doki Doki Doki Doki
Doki Doki Doki and Doki Hammer Doki.
Oops.
All of Doki's.
Slayer.
Oh, no.
Doki is.
I do not perceive.
Do that.
You heard you say his name.
He's like, Doki, that's me.
I'm Doki.
Oh, no.
Okay, I gotta check on what...
I use the bathroom anyway, so I'll be her back.
Alright, I'm back.
I think selecting the eyes is the hardest part, for sure.
I feel like there was more options in eyes.
And...
Oh, I'm so bad at the eyes part.
Because it's so...
It feels like they don't have an eye that's, like, me.
Oh, maybe this.
But I feel like her eyes being open would be good.
I'm not gonna draw the eyes.
Oh, yeah, that's scary, though.
I want something, like, smug.
What is he?
What are you doing here?
Why are you looking at me?
Huh?
Looking at me through the door.
Come in?
Oh, you want to come in.
There's nothing here.
Oh, it's locked.
Come on.
Why do you want to come in?
What?
What is it?
Oh, he came in.
He let him in.
He was like looking at me.
Yeah?
You're inside now.
You're here.
Okay.
I don't know.
I don't know what I do.
Do we want this?
Or...
Or have our eyes open.
He's gone now.
He came in just to be like, hi.
Hi.
Or like this.
Eyes closed or eyes open.
Open?
Okay, and we're doing open.
Maybe this one.
Maybe?
I feel like this eye.
Or maybe...
Wait, bottom right.
Yo, definitely not bottom right eye.
Okay.
Maybe this one?
Or this one.
I think this one would be good.
Maybe this one.
Alright.
Final call.
This side?
Or...
Really?
Actually, which one was the one I...
Oh my god.
I'm like...
I already lost track of all the eyes.
There was an eye that I liked.
Was it this one that I liked?
I don't remember.
I've lost track.
There's so many eyes.
Squish it a little bit.
I guess we could squish it.
Bottom right.
That one?
I remember my choices.
I already forgot which one I chose.
Oh, wait.
This one is nice.
I think it's the nose that's throwing me off.
Give me a sec.
The nose is definitely throwing me off.
Okay, wait.
I think we could draw the nose, right?
Alright, here we go.
There we go.
Alright.
Tilt those eyes up.
Oh, wait.
Wait, we're cooking here?
Oh, I think we're cooking.
Alright.
Thanks for always being awesome.
Any chance I can maybe get a happy birthday for my favorite
bird?
Of course!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Kingos.
Oh, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Kingos.
Happy birthday.
I realized I didn't want to sing a happy birthday Kingos to
you because that might be a little rude on your birthday.
But happy birthday.
Oh, we have a great birthday.
Thank you again for the Thank you.
Yeah, it's like, ooh, it'll be a little awkward.
We knew that.
I like these eyes.
I need to be further apart, though, for sure.
Yeah, we'll keep it like that.
And then...
Mouth.
Wait.
There we go.
Wait, wait.
I think that's...
Oh, it's perfect!
Is that or that?
Or are we doing this?
Oh, yeah, no.
This is good.
Yeah, yeah, this is perfect.
This is perfect.
She's back.
Oh, someone said...
The lower...
I don't know.
I don't think I lower any.
I think...
So I said lower the eyes a little.
We lower that.
We have to lower this too.
Oh, yeah, that works.
Let me try it.
Let me check it again.
I don't know.
Do we add...
Okay.
Do we do it lowered or...
Or do we...
Sorry.
Do we do lowered or keep it as it was?
Down is better?
Alright.
I think no is better.
might need to be higher than actually no nose is nose here
is good maybe smaller
yeah smaller nose right yeah smaller nose all
right there you go we got the ears is there like earrings no
they don't it's just glasses right what is this oh among us
wait I can make among us wait no no don't you focus on this
first but I could make I could make among us I focus on this
first Doki then we could think about the other special
residents on the island okay
base pink.
Let's add the little tail stuff.
Alright.
We're gonna see if I can draw this.
Okay.
We're gonna draw the white bangs first.
Pretty good.
Alright.
It's pretty good.
do this oh fuck okay and then we do this and then I can't
see my options so I gotta okay copy oh flip uh there we go I
I don't even remember where this is supposed to go.
There you go.
Very symmetrical.
Oh, shit.
No, it's not.
I gotta do this again.
Okay.
Uh...
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Copy.
Flip.
I just gotta see.
Oh.
There you go.
And then...
There we go.
We did!
it and then uh oh we can add the earrings you can add the
earrings too i'll put her here so i know what i'm doing and
then earring is what is that is that spade or a dot oh it's
a diamond wait i must have a shape right okay no not really
all right I can do this.
I need a smaller brush.
Average.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Okay, give me a sec, guys.
Okay.
Oh my god, diamonds are squared!
You're so right!
Okay.
I can just rotate a square what am i doing boom you're so
right a diamond is just a square rotated
amazing it just works
oh my god how to plug it we could do this Ah, there you go.
Boop.
There you go.
We did it.
I'm so smart.
All right, retro Doki is done.
Another Doki on Doki Island.
Easy.
It looks just like me.
All right, done.
We'll keep Retro Doki in the middle.
I think, actually, I actually think this is like perfect.
We can buy a hat, guys.
We'll buy a hat later.
What a quirky family we have here.
What is your muse name?
Doki.
My name is Doki.
it is actually my birthday today too don't worry you don't
have to sing it just want to say thanks for the
entertainment your streams and dragons always brighten my
day thank you for the super chat grandpa they get this i
almost said dokey there's just so many thank you for the
super chat dokey thank you thank you thank you the super
chat grandpa thank you thank you so many birthday goes today
congratulations happy birthday happy birthday to you Happy
birthday, dear Grandpa!
Happy birthday to you!
Yeah, happy birthday!
Of course I'll sing a birthday song for you.
Every dragon deserves a birthday song.
Where this one would be...
There you go.
Don't age.
My name is Doki.
How should we do this?
No, Doki.
Oh, shit.
You're right, you're right.
It should always be the classic.
My name is Doki.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is May 7th.
Alright, how do we do this, guy?
My name, my name is Doki.
Oh, retro Doki was that.
My name is...
My name is Doki.
It's nice to meet you.
Today.
My name is Doki.
It's my name is Doki.
It's nice to meet you.
My name is Doki.
It's nice.
It's nice to meet you.
My name is Doki.
My name- Which one?
One, two, four, five.
One, two, three, four, five.
Which one?
Not two.
Oh my god.
Five or six.
It's nice to meet you.
My name is Doki.
It's nice.
Five.
I see fives.
It's nice to meet you.
I'll do five then.
Yes.
Oh, no.
No.
Okay, she is quick.
She was a lot more polite back then.
She had a lot of energy.
She was not chill nor serious.
Oh, she was pretty chill.
Not gonna lie.
And she was not super quirky.
Ah!
I think so.
Yeah.
I know you were chill like that.
I was very chill.
I didn't take streaming seriously.
All right.
Is that good?
I don't know.
I knew I had a lot of energy and I was quick as fast as fuck
boy.
I think she was quicker.
If only I could go beyond this.
If only.
Put it here.
Alright.
She was.
There you go.
Everything.
Oh.
Oh yeah.
Pretty quirky.
Event outfits.
Uh...
Yeah.
Add me.
Outgoing!
Radiant always on form.
Their effortless style is my, but all and easily adapts to
new situations.
Optimistic and passionate follows their instincts.
Wait, what was...
What was...
Uh...
The other Doki?
What was the first Doki's...
Uh...
Personality.
I already forgot her personality.
Okay.
There's too many dokees.
They all blurred.
Oh, dokees next to dokees.
Why is the other dokees like exiled?
Okay, there.
Oh, go get her.
Nice to meet you.
That's just 22.
W.W.
W .W.
I'm dokees.
I'm an outgoing charmer.
I have a neck for bonding with others.
And I'm always ready for a good time.
Oh, yeah.
Before it.
Dokees, you were so young and off.
optimistic back then, Doki.
What happened to you?
Doki, you were so happy back.
You were so open and outgoing.
What do you mean you like to talk to people?
What the fuck?
Alright, here's some nachos, Doki.
Before she learned to be, before she was an adult.
Back when she had hopes and aspirations, before she moved to
New York city had to chase their dreams all
right let's give you a little pat doki before the accident
all right we have doki now oh oh we can make a wish oh
yeah wish granted
Oh, I still don't have anything new.
The little quirks.
I guess I'll do walking styles.
Oh, wait.
There's...
Wait, there's Doki and Doki are here.
Guys?
What are you talking about?
Good evening.
Oh?
I feel like I should up my fashion game now that I've got
some neighbors here on not related to other islands.
If everyone wouldn't be, let's see what we can do about
that.
Yay!
Now they can wear clothes.
Oh, me news.
Hey, Doki.
Oh, my God, Doki's on the channel.
Here's what's happening on our island.
At long last, not related to other islands, has its very...
We can get a hat!
We can't!
gathering outside the where and where to explain so this is
where pants come from and finally I can get past those no
shirt no shoes no service signs thanks for watching I'm Doki
and you're up to date we did it we're up to date now oh also
I hope the sound has been good so throughout I've I didn't
double check let's see Find something snazzy for Doki.
I don't know if they're at his shop.
Do you find them at Daily Specials?
Alright.
Any day slash you buy will also be at it.
Basic t-shirts.
Oh my god.
These are cute.
These are so cute.
Wait.
Do we maybe I should just move a little bit?
Maybe.
they're all so cute I want to see it more here these are
cute ass outfits are these like sets oh there's a hat but
it's not the hat we need what's the daily specials.
Oh my god, I could be a wizard.
Yo, wizard, Hedy.
Oh my god, wait a minute.
Is that...
Wait a minute.
That undertale?
Is that undertale right there?
Oh, I wanna...
Why is there an undertale outfit here?
I really want to buy Disco Star.
That's a good-ass outfit.
There's no cowboy outfit yet.
But I'm going to buy Disco Star.
Give me that Disco Star.
Alright, we got Disco Star.
And then...
I want to buy the...
Okay, we all buy this hat.
And then buy it.
Oh, wait, we only...
I am blue.
We'll buy this for now.
Yeah, but I could have a disco outfit, though.
That is sick.
That's a sick-ass outfit.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I want to buy the star pendant.
Give me that.
And then also the wizard.
Yay.
Hey, Doki.
What is it?
I want to talk to Doki, though.
Witch Doki!
Oh, this Doki!
I was like, Witch Doki's house!
I feel like I should up my fashion game now that I've got
some neighbors here on not related to other islands.
Oh, wait.
Here, I have a star pendant.
Wait, actually, I was gonna give this to tomato Doki.
But...
Witch Doki!
You had to go check Doki's house!
Which one?
Witch Doki, though.
I don't give Doki this.
Oh my god, she's so cool.
She's got crystal.
Yay!
I leveled up!
Are you facing the clock?
Kid-O-Matic!
What the fuck?
Wait, no.
No, you're not gonna be a kid.
What's expressions?
Oh, try spicing up your fun expressions that suit them well.
You can always swap them or delete them later.
Oh, wait,
I...
I have an idea.
Showning at the sea.
You're the sea.
Nothing.
Like and subscribe.
Wait, wait.
Wait, I got an idea.
Buy my merch.
There we go.
This is your new lingo.
Shameless plug.
Buy my merch.
It's as if that expression was made just for me.
Please, wild sad.
The joke, please.
Bye bye merch!
So every time you share merch you all Thank you with a super
chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Bye bye merch I'm so depressed.
Bye bye merch All right, nice Fucking stats So good Oh me
news Please bye bye merch We interrupt to bring you some
breaking news So, here's what's happening on our island.
Boy, there's only three of us.
Oh my god, how am I?
And for the news, we're hearing them.
TNC Railroad's account is likely to open once there are four
residents and two pairs of friends.
As of press time, it's unclear why the business has such
strict friend-based requirements, but I assure you that I do
not make the news.
You made the news!
Thanks for watching.
I'm Doki, and you're up to date.
Yay!
We're up to date!
Okay, I want to check out...
Because that Doki has been waving at me this entire time.
Wanna play red light?
Green light?
Red light, green light?
Sure.
You'll- we'll never run out of Doki's.
Uh, touching me without being spotted in order- okay.
Here we go.
light.
She doesn't have friends.
She has to play with God.
The other jokies don't want to talk to her right now.
What?
I didn't!
Whoa!
Don't worry, she'll finish soon.
No!
Hey, you can't win them all.
I got Constellation.
That's still a prize.
is a prize.
Kidding out played by.
I got toilet paper.
There's a fuck.
Oh, their treasure.
Well, maybe there's a million people who will be like it to
receive it as a gift.
It's probably a good time to mention that all of Ares' items
you obtain will be recorded in the item catalog.
Check it out sometime.
Item catalog.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
There's my treasure.
There's my toilet paper.
she's lonely all the other donkeys are afraid of her oh
dokey house okay dokey wants to talk dokey hey how you doing
good evening hey dokey all the new buildings here are not
related to other islands sure have made things more lively
walking between them would be a lot easier if we had some
past could you make some more
Alright, she wants me to terraform now.
And it's road time.
Oh!
Oh my god, there's roads now!
Whoa!
Oh my god!
My island is getting prettier!
That was fast?
Wow, I am, God.
Damn!
Doki, you know everybody!
Okay, our island is now a parking lot.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I'm on it.
Let's go, Doki.
She knows a guy.
All done.
Take a look whenever.
All right.
Thank you, Doki.
Wow.
She's so resourceful, guys.
She knows a guy.
Who knows a guy?
Let's see.
Check out what it looks like.
Oh, hey, Doki.
Are you excited?
Oh.
I'll bring someone over to help her.
Doki.
She can't stop hiccuping.
Take outside.
Doki, you're gonna have to help Doki.
Are you in trouble?
These kick, hiccups, they won't stop, kick.
How's...
There's the source of the problem.
Um, you might need to use a little moru.
What did Doki do?
Oh, wow.
Doki, what did you do?
What were the slapping sounds?
And now they're best friends.
Where are Lily?
My mom's in there!
I'm psyched!
Don't get out!
I don't know!
No!
Oh my god, it's too real.
I was going to Toki's house.
I can't help.
Toki's trauma dumping to Toki.
That's what you're doing.
All right.
Let me take a look.
What the fuck?
What is that?
Nicely done.
to the what was that got trip puttigo what the fuck is a
puttigo puttigo what is that puttigo use the cool water in
that why is that is a traditional Spanish poro clay porous
clay jug used to cool water naturally why is that in his
it's a sadly god what is that doing in my head all right oh
there's new goods gailam and air day give your men me plenty
of goods will help them have fun on the island oh okay we
have oh we got street dancing oh jogging laptop moroccas
okay but what is the little Oh wait, he has walks.
Okay, walks like a model, walks like a robot, walks by
balancing float.
Walk without swinging arms, walk with tiny...
Alright, do we do a float or walks with a swagger?
Do we float or walk with a...
Give tomato...
Swagger or tomato float?
He just floats.
He's like that Dragon Ball Z character.
Who was it?
The little guy?
Give the tomato.
Okay, I'll do a pull.
Yeah, Towsu.
Towsu.
Okay, I'll do a pull.
How to walk.
Float.
Bum, bum, bum.
Oh,
it's close.
It's pretty close, guys.
It's a D50.
It's neck and neck.
All right.
Here, float.
This is actually float.
Float.
And then swagger.
This is swagger.
Float.
He's just floating.
See, you can see his little...
Remember, we can give swagger or float to other dookies.
This is how he's floating.
Oh my god, the shine looks like he has a fucking...
Oh wait, what the...
Yeah, floating.
and then there's floating all right looks like swagger is
winning for those who are beyond walking wait for those who
are beyond meter walk guys that's it i'm making executive
decision i i didn't realize the description no sad look at
those wait if i make cooler doki cooler doki should get
swagger so we should do float for it yeah i would do float
and then and give swagger to cool doki.
That's right.
I'm here to teach you guys a lesson.
Voting doesn't matter.
I'm joking.
Voting matters.
You're really, really bad.
All right.
Here you go.
You're gonna float.
Yay, corruption.
Damn right, you do.
Oh, can I pet you again?
Will you give me more more juice?
Yay!
More wish juice?
No.
Doesn't give me more wish juice.
Oh!
Oh, you silly dokey.
You're so silly.
Oh, dokey wants to talk again.
Hey, dokey.
What do you mean?
We want to talk about.
It gets hard, Dr. No, it gets spooky here.
I'm not related to other islands after night, Paul.
Can we lighten the place up a bit by adding some street
lights?
Alright.
Oh, we have lights now.
Oh!
We have street lights!
Oh my god.
Everything looks so nice now.
Now we have utilities.
Now your means don't need to worry about tripping in the
dark.
Oh, because of that.
right donkeys we're not having a tap yeah let's fuck it
let's go i have a hundred i have 30 bucks let's get going
i'm parking lot now it's lights guys let's god on day three
god said let there be light all right yeah thanks dokey
all right
Dragon Ball Z character.
Where's the other Doki?
Oh, wait.
Are you looking at Doki?
Oh, what?
Oh, I just wanted to see what she was looking at.
Doki is bored and wants some company.
Oh, I know.
Alright, Doki.
You're going to give Doki company right now.
Alright.
Hey, nice to meet you.
I'm Doki.
You're Doki, I'm Doki.
Oh, yay.
Now they know a Doki now knows Doki.
Oh, oh my gosh.
She's talking about streaming.
Look at that.
She's like, oh, no.
Should I become, should I start streaming?
I don't know.
My friends are telling me about streaming.
I should try to start streaming.
I don't know why I should.
You're Doki.
I'm Doki.
The meaning of the words.
Oh, my God.
Crawling very specific.
Oh, remember that time when you made the door hallway?
The door hallway in Minecraft, Doki?
Oh, those are good times in the humble beginnings.
And Doki's by herself over there.
Doki, don't be a fucking loser, Doki.
Someone said they saw a cowboy outfit earlier, but I didn't.
I think that was a lie.
I see no cowboy outfit.
I see like this, but that's just plaid.
Plad doesn't mean Cowboy, guys.
This is getting a little too confusing.
Wait, I want Doki.
Doki, Doki, I got you a new outfit.
I forgot about it.
Doki, wear this.
You're gonna be a disco star, Doki.
Yay!
You're so cool, Doki.
All right, let's see.
Wish time.
Oh, yeah, Doki needs her hat.
Yay, level four!
Okay.
I get a new gift.
Grab a camera.
That's not gonna go...
Nothing's gonna go wrong there.
All right, let's give Doki the hat too.
something you need yes please wear the hat
no take off the hat take off the hat take off the hat dokey
can't take off the no take off the hat take it off it's god
take off the hat what the fuck is Wait, how do I make her
take it off?
Take off the hat.
No, it was a stink.
Take it off.
You don't want to take it off.
How do I get her to take it off?
The stinks are made.
No!
No, you're not allowed to like it.
Huh?
Yes.
Take off the hat.
Oh, clothing.
The hat stays off.
Get that hat off.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, no.
Okay.
The hat stays off.
Or should I give...
Make him a wizard.
She could...
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I should have given the disco star to Doki and then gave
the wizard robe to Doki.
Guys, yeah, the wizard tomato.
Because he's floating anyway.
All right, I'm going to give him another outfit.
Is disco better?
I feel like he's a floating wizard.
Check the tuck in top option.
Oh.
for hats it only works with low buttons wait tuck in top
what is that sorry I know I keep interrupting you guys good
evening good evening all right that's
guys nothing changed untucked up wait a minute oh what was
it before it's just literally the shirt i think it's cuter
like this what was it even before i don't even remember
all right should we give the tomato though i almost see fuck
it i'm gonna give tomato the wizard outfit too i think it'd
be fun i think it'd be funnier if he becomes a wizard
Here you get two outfits.
Here you go.
I want to see what looks.
Oh my god, he's so happy.
He gets everything.
He is the origin.
Remus will hang.
You get them even when they switch outfits.
But you want them to change into?
Just press Y.
Okay.
Y.
Alright, let's fix your...
Fix your outfits.
a little bit.
I don't know if I like the stars.
There we go.
You're my favorite.
Hello, Doki.
What are you excited about?
Oh, look, they're ants.
Oh my god, yeah, she's scared.
That's right, Doki.
You're scared of ants.
Is that it?
You're just looking at ants?
Oh, okay.
All right.
Okay, dokey.
All right, I think it's time.
I think it's time.
We can...
Oh, I saved.
And then we can add another resident on the island.
Don't stop.
Okay.
Me time.
From scratch.
Okay.
Let me think.
Who should I...
I had a really fun...
Oh my god.
There was one that I was...
Hmm.
What about Toki?
I had an idea for a dokey I wanted it I had an idea but I
lost it I'm thinking guys Decisions, decisions
Trying to think You know what
There was a dokey in my head, but I'm trying, there was
something not Doki related that thought it would be funny.
But I forgot which Doki, which not Doki.
Wait, wait, okay, wait.
Let me look at the Dokipedia.
Give me a sec.
Don't think too hard, Doki.
I gotta look at my Dokipedia.
I know which Doki.
Wait.
actually I do not know which dokey I know which dokey to add
I need know where this is going guys I don't
know where everything is gonna everything is gonna
me give me a sec I have actually left to look at a reference
real quick
remember when I said...
What is that?
Wait, let me give...
Oh, it is!
There we go.
And then we'll give...
And then...
We gotta...
I wish I could give him a backpack.
Look at his tiny eyes!
Oh my god!
Oh, maybe I can.
I can make it better.
Oh, my God.
How do I do the color?
The eye?
No.
I forgot.
I can't draw over it.
I can never draw over it.
I can't draw over glasses.
I want to.
I want to fucking smooth it out.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
It's okay.
Yes.
We'll have to take it off.
I'm sorry.
We're going to have to take it off.
But I have, like, a general idea on how I want it.
Don't worry.
Yes.
Okay.
And then we'll paint it over.
And then...
Oh, wait.
Okay.
We'll remove the eyes, too.
We'll remove the eyes.
later.
And it's like a lighter blue.
And then put it here.
And it will add.
Oh, shit.
I want paint behind it.
Oh, click the face icon to select.
Nice.
And then truly the greatest me of Among us.
And then.
Oh my god.
It's perfect.
Oh fuck.
It was actually perfect.
And then I deleted it.
It's too perfect.
Because I deleted it right after.
I don't know if I can.
If I can If I can recreate perfection No Rest to me No It
was actually Perfect guys
Okay Oh my god It can never be as perfect as that again It
can never be as perfect I can't believe I managed to fuck
that up.
Okay, wait.
Okay, it has to be like at least a little.
There we go.
It's perfect.
Maybe not that perfect.
Oh.
Alright.
As perfect as it can be.
I wish I have a back, but...
I think maybe I can make it...
There's something sus about this.
I think I can make this bigger.
I think it'd be better if it's bigger.
Actually, no, it would not be better if it's bigger.
Why do I have a new one?
Because we're adding another toky, guys.
But yeah, maybe I can put like a tiny mouth like...
Like right here.
I don't think so.
Actually, no mouth might be better.
Oh, big malware.
It could be the imposter.
He's the imp- The imposter.
There we go.
And you can tell these- It looks sus.
Nice.
I think we're good.
It has to be tiny, too.
But, like...
So he's also...
A chungus.
Oh, they're both red.
That's the only issue.
We could change the imposter color.
We might change the imp- I'm gonna change the imposter color
just because they're both red.
Okay.
Oh, the red is such a classic, though.
All right.
We'll make him yellow just to fit the theme, maybe.
Yeah, yellow.
I know, but then we have too many reds.
Man.
He needs a backpack, honestly.
He really does.
Oh, my God.
Wait, you're right.
guys we might we're pivoting we're pivoting i'm sorry we're
pivoting guys i know we just i think we have i know we just
made him but i'm deleting him i know i know we just made him
but we're gonna we're pivoting Pivoting right now.
There's something even better.
It gave me.
He got voted.
I got inspiration.
There's the eye.
How does it look like?
Oh, there it is.
I'm leaving.
Leave it.
I got I got inspiration Shout out to the dragon Shout out to
that one guy That gave me the most brilliant idea
Where is it?
Where is the glasses that we need?
Ben that guy You're all just jealous You didn't come up with
the same idea Yeah Jealousy doesn't look good on you,
dragon.
Okay.
And then...
This is how Tokey Island falls.
What kind of...
Do we want to give him the hair?
Which minion?
Do we want to give him Bob?
Or...
Okay, wait, there is...
Where is it?
Where is that hairstyle?
Don't let them be stolen, Quill.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god, I can make grew.
It's like Doki Island and grew and a minion.
Wait, this is a pineapple.
We have Doki Island.
fucking ruined minion.
They're also here.
They're also here, guys.
The quote that you gave in the super chat.
Thank you.
Because what I'm going to also have.
I don't know if I should let's see.
You don't have the hair I want to use.
They got the Doki Pass.
They're allowed in on Doki Island.
This would be a good minion hair, but we already have the
tomato with it too.
This is actually a minion hair as well, but I don't know.
Is that that or no hair?
But then Groo doesn't have hair, so I feel like we should
make Groo.
with regular oh wait this one no that does not that's just
homer simpson hair that's just the curl is we'll do curl
then it's just this thick of it i could draw it yeah but
then it wouldn't look right you know with i'm gonna draw the
maybe i'll draw the The goggles.
I'm gonna draw the goggles, though.
Alright, despicable me.
Oh, this guy gets it.
This guy gets it.
Despicable me.
Okay.
I want to grab this color, but how do I grab it?
Wait, okay, it's black.
There
we go.
Alright.
Alright, and then...
Oh.
Poop.
Uh...
Copy.
Alright.
How does that look?
Never die!
Never mind that's a...
Never mind that is...
Never mind.
That doesn't work.
It looks pretty.
Wait, I got it.
I got it.
I have an idea.
Uh.
There's a website.
Where's the website?
There's a web.
Someone must have.
Oh my god.
Minion.
Someone...
Wait, how did they do this?
How the fuck?
I knew someone can make a better minion than me.
I knew.
Oh my god, they're so much smarter.
Wait, I knew it.
I knew I was missing something.
I was missing something.
Wait, how do I do it?
How do they do the eyes?
Wait, those eyes are so smart.
They made Kevin.
I need to fix the eyes.
They're so smart.
They're so right.
It should be all the way up here.
Okay, who the fuck is Kevin?
Okay, it was this.
And then the eye color was that.
It was like that.
I'm on something.
And then...
How do I...
How do they do the eyes, though?
Is it face paint?
How do they make the pupils black?
How the fuck did they do that?
Oh, shit.
That's too scary.
Yeah, but it's white here.
Oh, my God.
That is so smart.
Oh, my.
Oh my god!
Do you see the vision?
Do you, dragons, do you see the vision?
I still like this more.
I wish I didn't.
Do you guys see the vision?
Do you see it?
We might make Kevin, honestly.
Kevin seems to work well the most.
I might have to use this.
Because it looks like Kevin more.
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
How do I specifically grab that color though?
I want to grab this color.
Why are you like this?
Oh, I have to figure it out myself.
That's fine.
Oh.
Put it out here.
Alright.
And then, we do this.
And then, flip it.
Oh, I don't know why I have to flip it.
It's literally two circles.
And then...
And then we change the color.
Oh, wait, not that.
And then...
Because that's not the right color.
It's lighter.
Boom!
And then...
Oh, oh.
Oh, fuck.
I don't...
Okay, it might be a little too much.
Like...
And then we do this, yeah.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
And then we do this.
we add a little okay
maybe not oh maybe not all right okay maybe this is not
looking as good as I thought it would be maybe it's not
looking as good as I thought oh wait outline oh my
god wait that That looks amazing.
Well, not really, but I'm like coping a little bit.
And then...
Oh my god.
The shading, guys!
The shading!
Wait.
Wait, the 3D effect?
Wait a minute.
Wait, let's see if it's better.
I'll wait the 3d effect illumination on Wait I think the 3d
effects makes it better That actually makes it a lot better
Wait a minute It makes it so 3d guys RTX on
They're illuminating the eyes
The illumination on guys
Traffic I forgot if I like your illumination on or off.
Okay, we're going to keep it off.
I think I'm making it worse.
I'm making it worse as I keep going.
I'm already too committed, guys.
What?
We're already too committed.
We got to see it to the end.
You gotta see it to the end
Okay How
do I make sure I
Okay Copy
Alright Okay.
Okay, wait.
I think I actually take the glasses.
Let me take the glasses off and see if it proves it.
Oh!
Yes, Ashley, it's so good.
I'm so proud of myself.
Okay, let me fix it a little bit.
That little spot is getting rid of this little spot.
but there we go there we go
it's kevin
okay the laughter of pure joy i'm putting so much okay okay
we do the actual mouth it would be
Hey, minion, let me look at what is his actual mouth is
like, it's like this, I'm very sure is it like that?
No, it has actual teeth.
All right, I'm trying to figure out which one.
Okay, guys, which one?
This is not Kevin.
There's Kevin.
Okay, one, two.
Oh, hey, it hurts.
Watch.
I think I like one.
I don't like, I'm going to...
Okay, we got Kevin.
We have Kevin.
Guys.
We have Becky.
What was even two?
I don't even remember.
Is this Kevin?
Alright, one.
I don't know how I should make it smaller or bigger.
Okay, definitely.
What did I just join into?
It's Kevin!
Oh, definitely lower.
Here we go.
All right, we have Kevin.
Oh, maybe smaller for sure.
Yeah, there we go.
All right.
You needed these stuff.
Okay.
All right.
They took you said a minion.
I don't know if I want to keep the hair.
We could.
Can't use a different hair.
I don't know if I want to keep.
We could just make him bald.
Wait, actually, what does he look like if he's just bald?
Because, like, the only issue I have is that his hair is the
same hairstyle.
No, he needs hair.
He needs Kevin needs hair Kevin We have to you keep that
Wait can I make his head longer Oh my god wait I can't
Alright There we are Oh bottom middle Oh Oh Oh Oh That's
okay Okay We okay.
And then we gotta...
We gotta keep the mouth.
There we go.
Yeah, we have to lower the mouth.
You want dark?
Thank you for the silver chat.
Thank you.
Okay, we do want to make it more minion-like.
It would be this.
It would be this mouth.
Actually, it might fit Kevin more if it was.
Or It's this But we rotate it
Flatten it a little bit
And then Or Why is this so good?
Alright There's so many options, guys.
This?
Okay, not that.
God, there's so many good options.
There's so many good options.
I don't know which one to pick, guys.
Do we get the...
Or do we give him just...
The default...
The default is this.
Did we do the default?
Okay.
Or defy the default.
There we go.
It's good, it's good, it's good.
Alright, I think we got it.
I think we got Kevin.
I think we got...
Do we call him Kevin or Minion?
Do we call him Kevin or Minion chat?
He is a little taller.
Well, he's a tiny bit taller than the Tim...
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Kevin the Minion.
I don't even know if it fits.
We'll see.
The Minion.
I think that's actually the most nice tab I've spent.
my name is kevin the minion
kevin from kevin from the minions oh wait my name is kevin
the minion my name is kevin the minion kevin can i fit a can
i fit more kevin from the minions
No!
If I could fit more.
My name is Kevin the Minion.
Kevin from Minion.
Do you do Kevin the Minion?
Is this your way of announcing a Minion Tokiwa?
Right.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Kevin the Minion.
We use Kevin from Minions?
Sorry, Kevin the Minion.
My name is Kevin the Minion.
Kevin from the Minions movie.
Kevin from...
The Minions of a movie.
Is that Kevin from the Minions movie?
From the Minions.
a movie there you go Kevin from the minions movie my name is
Kevin from the minions movie okay and then and then Kevin oh
shit my name is Kevin Kevin there it my name is Kevin my
name is Kevin from the minions movie
oh wait i said like kevin the minion kevin the minion is
pretty good i'm sorry i keep backtracking was just pretty
good i am so proud of myself kevin the minion it's such a
good rhyme
the minion the minion
okay My name is Kevin the Minion.
Kevin from the Minions.
Is that Kevin from the Minions movie?
Kevin from...
From the...
Minion!
From the Minion.
Oh, from the Minion?
No, no, no, Minion?
Movie.
Minions movie.
There you go.
Do I go backwards?
Oh, shit.
I forgot to put S from the Minions movie.
Oh, I'm so proud of myself.
Is that Kevin from the Minions movie?
My name is Kevin from the Minions movie.
When did the despicable me?
When did the despicable?
Oh yeah, he should be a kid.
Let's give it...
When did this Pickable Me come out?
Pickable Me will be come out.
1940.
Okay, July 9th.
Oh my, everybody's a July, baby.
Okay.
It will be...
One year or so.
Don't age.
So none.
opinions that's true 20 actually oh
my god he's just 17.
okay oh he'll be a kid do we want
okay technically we could make him 18.
what what the no it's kevin it's kevin from the minions oh
you're right wait you're right i forgot they're technically
uh i forgot you know how they were supposed to be in
hibernation from uh 19 like 1890 to like 1960 or something
so like because their whole thing is
um they always serve the most evil leader in the world so
they're like oh by the way during the 1890s to 1960 they
were in hibernation because they wanted to avoid world war i
too so so so the so they didn't want to think about the
minions might have worked for hitler or something
this problem how do we fix it yeah so you're like during
that time the minions were in hibernation so they couldn't
so nothing so they did not serve anyone during that time
period it's crazy wait what do the minions minions movie i
think that's nice to meet you the minions boys so how does
this voice sound let me listen to my name is kevin from the
minions okay it has to be higher to meet you my name is
kevin my name is kevin from the minions movie i'm listening
it's nice to meet you today my name is kevin from the minute
my name is kevin from the minions my my name is kevin from
Today is May 2nd, 2026.
So, how does this voice sound?
My name is Kevin from a minions movie.
My name is...
It's nice to meet you.
My name is Kevin from a minions movie.
Today is May 2nd, 2026.
My name is Kevin from...
My name is Kevin from a minions movie.
It's nice to meet you.
There you go.
My name is Kevin from a minions movie.
from the minions movie my name is kevin my name is kevin my
name is kevin from the minions movie bastard my name is
kevin my name is kevin from the minions movie my my name is
kevin from the minions movie it's nice to meet you all right
do we do picture deaf higher so how does this voice sound my
name is kevin from the minions movie it's kevin from the
minions movie it's kevin the Minion!
Awesome!
My name is Kevin, my name is Kevin from the Minions movie.
It's nice.
No, no.
My name is Kevin from the Minions movie.
There we go.
It's the Kevin!
Yes.
Alright.
He's not related to anybody.
He is quick as fuck.
He's very quirky.
Wait, Kevin's the more serious one though.
He's like...
He has a lot of energy.
And then...
But he's more polite.
He is more polite.
He's the...
I don't...
Thank goodness.
Alright.
Yes, they are.
They're pretty fast.
They're pretty fucking fast.
He is very single and ready to mingle, guys.
Yeah.
Kevin.
Actually, Minya's like the cross dress.
So Otter's okay.
he's the smart one exactly yeah he's the smart one
all right we're ready kevin thoughtful honest innocent does
things at their own pace idealistic and romantic often has
their heads in the class and finds a lot of great I spent
over 30 minutes on Kevin and it was worth it.
I didn't realize I was gone.
I was so busy working on Kevin.
I forgot I wasn't even on the screen.
I was so passionate about Kevin.
I'm a good sinner at daydreamer.
I know I look like I have it all together, but I've been
known to overthink things now and then.
I hope we get along well.
so locked in trying to make kevin
all right hello kevin hello kevin are you not gonna let me
pat you there we go Yay!
We could have Among Us by Kevin the Minion.
Joki, Joki, and Kevin.
Alright.
Oh yeah, Kevin, you want and it looks like and can't move.
I'll bring someone over.
Oh no, he's so scared.
we bring over?
Let's bring Doki over.
Alright, Doki, you're going to meet Kevin the minion.
Howard, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ta-da!
Am I too up to something?
Well, please help me.
Wait.
What?
What's he doing?
Doki, what are you doing?
Oh!
Okay, everything is fine.
No need to thank me.
like-minded oh look they're good friends now let's go what
did they do they're very like-minded people
look they're talking to each other i keep floating oh wait
doki wants help hello doki good evening Uh, I've been
thinking too hard.
Oh, that's not good.
That's not a good thing, Doki.
That's not good.
Clear my mind.
What the fuck is that?
Doki, what's in there?
What the fuck is in my Doki's heads?
You?
My loofah?
What the fuck?
Yeah, thinking's bad.
Thinking only causes more problems.
them.
Classic Doki, that's.
Don't you hate it when you think about loofas?
Oh, what do we give?
I don't want to give.
You know what?
Let's give.
See, little quirks.
Oh, Doki doesn't have this yet.
Let's see.
I want
I want I want to like a model.
I feel like I want to That's right.
Actually, cutely?
I don't know.
I guess.
I either model or cutely.
Or it could be the standing one.
Yay!
I feel like standing smuggly or over me.
All right, let's see.
Yeah.
Oh, okay, smug.
I like smug for this.
All right.
Here you go.
Your new quirk.
Yay, it stands smugly now.
I feel a bit more like myself.
Yay.
Okay.
Why are you always by yourself, Doki?
Oh, you want company?
Alright, don't worry.
I'll grab Doki over.
Wait, I'll grab Kevin the Minion.
What are they doing at Doki's house?
Oh, they're playing.
Alright, you're leaving.
Goodbye.
You gotta meet the other Doki.
She wants company.
Kevin the Minion.
Hey, nice to meet you.
I'm Doki.
Nice to meet you, Doki.
I'm Kevin from the Minions movie.
getting acquainted so why he went into a new battle he's
trying to make Kevin play marble rivals and she needs her
people to play with Maria what a legendary meetup he was
like please play marble rivals I need someone to play with
me Hey.
Sir?
Uh, when do I start unlocking newer outfits?
I guess because it's updated daily.
Oh my god, I can't wait to get overalls.
Please play, take.
Hello?
What is it?
Doki?
I got two big friends with Doki.
Which one?
Oh, Doki.
other dokey yes what should we talk about right okay all
right an action a person a thing in action what should we oh
yeah um what would retro doky like
Oh, A.
Okay.
No, wait, wait.
What did you have in mind?
Look, I had a really...
I had a phase, alright?
Alright.
I had a phase.
Sense of detail.
Oh, that's sense of detail.
Sense!
Look, I had a phase.
phaser right had a phase with sands and i was a a big fan of
sands undertale i know me i know she would love sands
undertale sure but i wonder quick joki can this is your
sands undertale impression why sands undertale impression
i've never tried before but i'm feeling brave How's this?
Party home.
Look at me.
I'm sense under town.
That's perfect.
You sound just like them.
Oh my god.
It's so good.
You're so talented.
Doki.
You.
You wanna be friends.
It was so good.
It was perfect.
That's what he would say!
The voice is close!
Kandali, thank you for the super chat, thank you!
Kevin from the Minions movie!
Return to Avengers Doomsday!
Yay!
We're now good friends!
Go ahead.
Doki.
I still can't believe it was just an impression.
I'm so...
impressed who I gotta learn some more words yay we leveled
up all right let's give I want him to learn how to street
dance all right it's time the street dance the
wizard only grows more power foot look at that are you okay
gazing up in the night sky there you go dokey everyone else
is making friends dokey what the fuck are you doing dokey
she's such a loner oh i'm a new gift
Minion?
Grab a soccer ball.
She's staring at the moon.
She wants to steal the moon after meeting Kevin the Minion
from the Minion's movie.
Oh, she went home.
Joki went home.
She's disassociating.
Just as always.
Good evening.
What do you want?
Yeah?
I wanna chat?
Sure.
Huh?
Are you the competitive type?
It's so accurate.
Well, if you could pick any type of competition to
participate in, what would it be?
Let's see.
In the world you live in.
Teach them all you can by taking time.
When you teach them what you teach them will spread across
as island lingo, which the muse will start using regular
conversation.
You, the island, anytime, all right?
Is an activity I compete in.
I need to go in my nose real quick.
Bada-dum, bum, bada-dum.
Being...
Okay, wait.
Oh shit, wait, uh, nothing.
Oh, this is hard.
Oh, what can I do?
NAP, gotcha.
Oh, wait, I got an idea.
Yes.
Oh, I can totally see that.
You speak?
Looking at the podium after Gamba.
Yeah!
Gam-Doki, no!
I taught Doki a new word.
I taught Gamba.
All in.
The more I look at it, the more I realize she looks just
like me.
Because it is me.
Oh, what is it?
How about a quick game of no repeat?
No repeats.
Alright.
I'm putting the name of a food.
The game ends if someone picks something that isn't.
No, it eats food.
Cellar?
Oh, oh, oh!
Cell-feld!
I can't see the word!
I just ate this.
Cell-feld focused on food.
Dude.
I just could, I couldn't see it.
I just want a self-help book.
Okay, maybe I should do a left-side Doki.
Give me a sec.
I realized that maybe I should have been left-side Doki as a
tie.
I got a box of tissues, though.
Alright, Doki's house.
Good evening.
What do you want, Doki?
It doesn't really match my butt.
It doesn't?
Chair.
Doki wants to renovate her home if only there is some sort
of facility that she could you could use to do that.
Is there?
New place!
New house!
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
Here's what's happening on our island.
A renovation center has officially opened on not related to
us.
Thanks, Kevin.
The local TNC Renew Home Supply Sales Interior Set, which
can bring new...
You're blocking the view, Dad.
I gotta put you down.
I mean, not like that.
Put him down from my head.
He's put him.
And then put him off my head.
No.
Let's let him down shopper.
And that would make it too happy.
Every Monday.
This is a TNC and Reno Thumbs.
That's why Cadlock.
They're always available to purchase.
Alright, overdose.
Polkadot.
Simple living.
The fucking garage set.
That's...
Oh, I want to...
We'll buy this.
Thank you very much.
Please come again.
We'll buy this one for Doki.
Uh, here we go.
This place doesn't really match my vibe.
Can we change up this room's look?
Don't worry, I got you, Toki.
House editor.
Boom.
Ah, it's so...
Oh, don't exit.
Yes.
Affirm.
You like it, Toki?
Donkey loves it!
Yay!
This is exactly the kind of room I wanted to live in.
Thank you.
Yay!
Donkey's happy!
Interior partnership plays a restore where you're blind, so
renovate your heart out.
Alright, Donkey's happy now.
Oh, new me news.
Hey, Doki.
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
Here's what's happening on our island.
Not related to other islands is now capable of sustaining
five individual lives, meaning another resident can move to
the island, and we can finally field a basketball team.
We've also received word that a quick build amenities is
likely to open some time after that fifth special someone
arrives.
Oh, it's time to make a fifth special.
for watching i'm doki and you're up to date guys it's time
oh wait new new wishing fountain
oh new wishes are available do you want to wish for new set
you'll get one as a gift oh i want that oh Oh my god, a dog
house set.
That'll be perfect for later.
Okay, a potty set, tea house set, ornate, camel, sugar rush.
Do I need more?
There is more.
Athletic, emperor.
Okay, we gotta grab this for the future.
I have enough warm fuzzies.
How many warm fuzzies do I have?
Oh, I don't have it yet.
Yeah, oh, I need to level it up.
Okay, I just don't have it.
Okay, Kevin, the minion.
What you doing up there, looking at that light pole?
Look at him go.
Look at Doki, go.
Hey, Doki.
Then keep funking.
Oh, he was street dancing.
Oh, there he goes.
Yeah, go Doki.
Go.
Oh, wait, Doki wants to talk again.
Huh?
Oh my god, we have a Roomba?
It may just be my imagination, but I get the feeling of
Doki.
You sure about that?
Ask for a date.
Wait, no, yeah, ask Doki for a date.
Oh!
My feelings are platonic.
Oh, rejected, and he would never know.
Toki will never know.
Would that?
Toki has a crush on Toki, and Toki will never know.
I have an idea.
Like I said, wait.
Oh my god, wait.
Alright, I'm ready.
I don't think I need any face paint, guys.
We gotta move over again.
Watch this.
It's this shape, right?
no no it's not sense it's not sense guys it might be
something even better than sense i told you what i was gonna
make guys i oh god i told you guys exactly what i was gonna
make
you find the right eyebrows.
What was
this?
Oh, no, it's thicker.
Oh, it was this.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
Wait, that's perfect.
Is this gonna be so good?
I'm so proud of myself.
Oh my god.
I need to put more effort into this.
Wait, it's all coming together.
Is this this nose or is it?
Oh, it's this nose.
Oh my god.
Wait, I need to drive.
I need to figure out how to make this.
Oh, it has to be the eyes.
I think it's the idea of flattening the eyes more.
And then, Steve Carell asked.
Where, I mean, they're almost there.
All right, and then, oh man.
I think the eyebrows need to be a little longer.
No, I think this is fine actually.
Oh my god, it's the eyebrows.
I need to, I don't know if I, oh maybe it's the eyes that
are too big.
There we go.
Wait, wait, wait.
I think I got it.
I think I got it, guys.
Okay.
I think got it.
Okay, but then...
It put it turned into some pigeons.
Okay, everything's going to come together.
The moment.
Does he not remind you of anybody?
That's how...
Why am I not surprised?
Guys, it's grew.
It's grew from the minions.
Guys, it is.
Why is this so much better than the toky's?
Why is this?
Let's see what I want.
There we go.
All right.
This way come up.
I get it.
You all get it.
B.
I'm trying to remember if the head is the right shape.
Oh yeah, no, this is the right head shape.
Maybe like if the eyebrows are turned down a little.
Oh, that's when he's sad.
Okay, let me...
Groo!
okay he just needs the scarf and there's a scarf there's a
scarf in the in the store right now I remember and I saw it
I saw the scarf cats all right I think we're done
toky toky toky at the speakable me
All right Groo
I grew My name is Groo.
My name is Groo Groo I think you just beep Groo Groo versus
speakable me I don't know if that work.
Okay I grew
From...
The fruit from the me...
Dispicable...
I have the despicable...
Me...
Movie.
My name is Groove from Despicable Me Movie.
Despicable?
That didn't I spell it wrong!
This spike- this- Oh, Despicable- Okay, okay, I was like- My
name is Groove from Despicable Me Movie
Alright Man When did this- Oh yeah, it was awesome- When
did- When did the minion- Did the Minion movie come out?
Oh, July 10th.
Oh, also July 10th.
Wait, what did, wait, what, what, what year was grew aboard?
April or May 1964.
Okay, we'll do.
And March, April.
That's four.
And then 1960.
There we go
My name is grew from mine my name how does from despicable
how does grew sound grew Nice to meet you grew voice lies
second 2026 How does this voice sound?
My name is grew from despicable me movie.
Okay, it's not my name is grew.
How do we make it my name is my My name is Groove from...
My name is Groove from Despicable Me...
My name is Groove from Despicable...
My name...
My name is Groove from Despicable Me Movie...
My name is Groove from Despicable...
My name is Groove from Desp...
My name...
My name is Groove from Despicable Me Movie...
I think it'd be three!
My name is Groove from Despicable Me...
My name is Groove from this Peck-O-Bully movie.
It's nice.
My name is Groove from this Peck-O-Bully.
My name is Groove from this Peck-O-Bully movie.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is May 2nd, 2026.
So, how does this voice sound?
My name is my name.
My name is Gru from Despicable Me Movie It's nice to meet
you My name is Gru from Despicable Me Movie It's nice to
meet you Today is May 2nd, 2026 So, my name is Gru from
Despicable Me Movie It's nice to meet you Today is May 2nd,
2026.
I think we're almost there.
This voice sound.
My name is Groove from Duska Gopalmi movie.
It's nice to meet you.
I'm like listening to Groove voice lines right now.
You're gonna do a higher pitch or lower?
Okay, maybe a little higher.
All right, I think that's good, right?
Lower.
It's nice to meet you.
No, no.
My name, my name, my name is Groove from this The Gobble Me
movie.
My name is Groove.
There you go.
Perfect.
Wait, wait.
Use the parent of Kevin the Minion.
Alright.
Use his dad.
All right, there we go.
So at least they won't fall in love.
We got preventative measures.
So that Gru and Kevin do not fall for the best.
It's for the best, guys.
That Gru and Kevin do not fall in love.
But that's true.
But what if?
Wait.
Fine.
Cowboys are fine.
We'll let fate decide.
I'm just gonna let...
He's pretty quick.
And he's honest.
He's pretty flat.
And he's very serious.
And he is not...
Well, he's not normal.
What I'll do here
About a book straight talker puts a premium on results a
Determined self-starter cuts their own path letting nothing
stand in their way Quick, oh my that's totally grew that's
definitely grew up he has a wife guys oh wait kevin oh wait
then he'll never get married to kevin hey you must be
duchess 22 w w w w w w w w w it's nice to meet you my name
is grew from this I'm an ambitious maverick.
I want to experience everything this world has to offer.
I live life on my own terms and try to be my own me.
Thanks in advance for looking after me here.
Yay!
We did it.
I need to edit you.
Sorry, Gru.
I need to edit you real quick.
I need to make sure that anything can happen in the doki
first.
But in the doki first.
You want nachos, Gru?
It's doki's and Gru and Kevin.
Yum.
Oh, he likes it.
He really liked it.
all right let's oh grew let's go by grew his scarf i
remember seeing a scarf there
oh there it is oh my god there it is wait what does grew
where does he wear Oh, it depends on the shirt.
Okay, do we have, like, a shirt, a black pants for him?
Oh, we do.
We actually do.
Okay, and then the sitter's turtlenecks.
Oh, my God.
Oh, it doesn't come in black.
We have to take what we can get.
This one does.
Perfect.
Where's Groo?
Groo!
Oh my god, Groo!
What are you doing?
What the fuck is Groo doing?
Good evening!
Alright, Groo.
I gotta give you...
your scarf.
Not shady at all.
Alright, Groo's happy.
Oh, I got more for you, Groo.
It fits.
Oh, he doesn't like it.
It's too bad.
This is who you are, Groo.
You were meant to wear this.
Oh, Maya.
There he is.
He likes it.
This is your... It's literally your fit.
Let me go, we've made Groot.
Kevin, are you okay?
Oh, I'll bring someone.
Oh my god, where's Groot?
Groot!
Kevin, the minion needs your help!
Are you all right?
Please, pick, help me.
Little offense.
Let's go, Shabazz.
Oh, I'm starting to feel better.
He did it.
Groove helped save them.
You're so kind.
Don't worry.
After this stream, I'm going to reward myself with hot pot.
Yay!
Please fall in love.
Hey, Doki.
Doki's stall.
Look at them.
Yes, Doki?
Nothing beats a good set.
Can we get a bench around here?
Yeah, I can get you a bench.
Well, it's nice to take it, but how does one go about
acquiring a bench?
Do I have a new...
Yay!
Midnight hot pot soon.
We grew up to bring you...
Oh my god, he looks so good at suit.
on our island.
A shop where one can purchase amenities and facilities for
the island has arrived at our shores.
Known as Quick Build, the shop sells buildings, objects, and
other things necessary for making the island drone.
One resident is quoted as saying, you mean I can go and do
this building and buy a whole different building.
If you say so.
Thanks for watching.
I'm Drew from Despicable Me movie.
And you're up to date.
Looks like a quick build menus.
Go buy a bench.
Alright, we gotta turn that dream.
He talks so slow.
All right, that's all I want.
We'll have a good economy here, guys.
All right, bench.
Island building.
Place the bench where you're like, okay.
Oh, well, she wants it here.
All right.
Here's your bench.
Okay.
My dream bench.
Now I can engage in some high-octane relaxing...
Okay.
Yay!
We're so rich!
We had $250 in our savings account.
Nice, really nice.
Always good to see a dream come true.
Adventures are just the beginning.
Try placing different objects around the island.
Your meme may interact with them in unexpected ways.
You have the power to make the island into a paradise or a
playground or whatever else feels right for your memes.
however you want the island to look quick build amenities is
a place to shop for what you need it seems like they have
some new inventory ready be sure to check it out often
another mini news oh my god hell i've been playing for four
hours all right guys i see i see the way now i see the way
oh my god six thank you bro fun times to give us it i'm also
made to dragon can't get happy birthday just before the day
ends.
Wait, what do you say?
Trips, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, and happy birthday!
Don't worry, Gru's gonna take another 20 years to finish
this sentence.
But happy birthday!
So many dragons birthday!
Happy birthday, too.
Oh, wait, that was Doki.
Sorry, I got confused.
Doki, not Doki.
Trips.
Thank you so much.
I'm getting confused.
There's so many Tokyo's and Gru's and Despicable Me's.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Trip.
Happy birthday.
Same with Autumn.
Happy birthday to you too.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
as of 30 minutes ago.
New birthday.
Of course.
Happy birthday to you as well.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Autumn.
Yay!
So many birthdays.
Thank you again.
All right, we should grab a vending machine.
Let's buy one real quick.
We have the funds.
All right.
And then...
Builder.
Where do I...
Oh.
Where do I put my weeds?
Oh my god.
I can't see myself.
Oh, it's build.
Okay.
Uh, vending machine.
Let's put that.
You know what?
Let's put it.
Right here.
Oh, actually not right there.
right here yeah
you know amuse will use items that you place on the island
all by themselves but sometimes they'll also react when you
drop them on top of it so trees benches vending machine oh
they give us super chat thank you thank you it's not my
birthday can I have a not birthday sign no thank you it's a
super chat thank you thank you how do you think your amuse
might react to some of those items well there's only one way
to find out drop dropping them on various items and see what
happens that's right you gotta wait all right kevin i'm
gonna drop you at the vending machine what you gonna do
kevin oh who would have thought he bought he bought a drink
oh my god who would have thought guys if you if you drop
something at a vending machine something at the vending
machine that's crazy what an insane discovery it's more
unlikely than you think level six oh my god oh new wishes
you also see one new items as a bonus gift.
What can I get?
Any road sign?
Oh, wait.
All of these are trash.
Not gonna lie.
How about this?
I have new cards.
Oh my god, my soul building.
We need that.
Nice.
Okay.
And then...
Oh, there's new stuff in here.
I thought we already saw the new stuff.
Oh, oh, I didn't see that.
Never mind.
There's flowers.
Oh, there's shot.
Oh, wait, no.
I already have these.
Please come again.
Oh, Gru wants something.
When you want Gru.
Good evening.
Got a little set.
i want to chat yeah sure oh i'm curious what kind of people
you're into
it's gonna be a while oh that's hard that's hard that's a
hard question Russian.
A celebrity I like.
That's difficult.
This could have been Satin's Undertale.
Oh, yeah.
The keeper.
Oh, you like the keeper.
That's just 22 I'm so blue That's my favorite celebrity,
guys Oh, really?
Oh my god!
I'm Gru's number one I'm Gru's number one celebrity Oh my
god, Gru I love the purple shoes, too I'm Gru's favorite
celebrity, guys I'm so honored.
Doki, meet Kevin.
Okay, yo.
Hey, nice to meet you.
I'm Doki.
Nice to meet you.
Doki.
I'm Kevin from the minions movie.
Yay!
They're in queenesses now.
Okay, long world, because they're from the same age.
Okay.
Alright, guys.
Seems like mining.
Yeah, 150 and 69 are pretty close together.
Doki is...
You're such a freak, Doki.
You're such a loner.
Stop interacting with the people around you.
Everyone is making friends.
You know what, Doki?
to be them oh my gosh she's eavesdropping no do not fall in
love with kevin the minion
toky socialize oh my gosh she's third wheeling oh my god
toky stop oh my god toky Doki, when would you learn?
She likes to watch.
You would do that.
Oh my god.
Guys, I understand now.
I understand Tomodachi life.
I get it now.
I get it.
I sighed.
I put it off for so long.
But I get it now.
I understand.
Alright guys.
Oh my I have to call it here.
I have to come out to wake up super early tomorrow.
Wait what?
What a journey.
Yes I will stream it again.
I understand now.
We'll have more Tomodachi life fun time.
Anyway guys.
Thank you all for coming.
to doki island don't worry doki island will return will
return in tomodachi life hey guys as always everybody stay
hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that
blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed because
you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye
guys bye oh oh they're done too they're like troops over
let's all leave Thank you, everyone.
Bye.